Mrs virtual meeting of the Council on
the 18th of February 2021. my first
store reminds you of some domestic
arrangements before we continue into the
meeting first ensure your microphones
are muted when they're not when you're
not speaking that your cameras are
located in the correct position so what
that really means is that we don't have
just eyes and foreheads so if you could
just check your position that'd be
fantastic on an O3 in the evening that
position changes if you could just
readjust it that'd be excellent thank
you
um that you don't interrupt other
speakers uh when they're speaking please
use the raised hand facility if you wish
to speak but please refrain from using
the Emojis I know some of you found them
uh we're only going to use the hands up
facility uh when uh in this meeting
members are reminded not to use the
messaging chat function during the
meeting unless it's just reports a
pecunery or non-pecuniary interest or to
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal
that's if you're attending the meeting
to speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
Additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection to the meeting you must
contact the member Support Officer Mandy
Smith as soon as possible he will try
and get you back into the meeting as
this is a virtual meeting you will not
need to stand to address the chair
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
kind of move to the agenda please and
apologies for absence
chair I have
this for absence thank you thank you
Declaration of Interest by councilors in
accordance with delegate the delegated
authority the monitoring officer has
granted dispensations to all members in
respect to the 2122 budget papers do we
have any other decorations
okay moving on
we're now going to move to the minutes
of the previous meeting held on January
the January 21st 2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with the accuracy
of the minutes
councilor Mansell
uh thank you chair I I'm not sure if
this is actually a mistake or whether
there's just the numerical
um whatever it is you know bullet point
things that I don't seem to quite tally
on page 174 uh where we were talking
about the uh changes to the outside
bodies
um I think some of the numbers uh don't
seem to make sense to me so I'm not sure
if I've misread them or the numbering of
the actual resolutions is not doesn't
quite tell you with what was in the
agenda
okay thank you that is noted uh thank
you for diligence that'll be corrected
if there is an error there thank you
so can we have a proposal please for the
accuracy of those minutes
okay councilor mayor
and a second to please
counselor Phillips
I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councilors could you
please open the vote in the modern.gov
app by clicking the plus sign in the top
right hand of the agenda screen and
slicking selecting attendance and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this
agenda item will show in blue please
click on the blue line to open the vote
thank you
chair that that the votes are all for
oh thank you the minutes of the meeting
have been confirmed and they will be
signed to the next practical opportunity
we now move to the leaders announcements
I'd like to invite councilor Morley to
present our update councilor Morley
please
councilor Morley are you there
my apologies chair no problem thank you
we have significant budget debates to
consider tonight together with a number
of questions and amendments I will not
give a lengthy leaders announcements I
did however want to quickly highlight a
few things
firstly in relation to covid the
progress that has been made in recent
weeks with regard to the delivery of the
vaccine has been amazing
despite the snow this progress has
catapulted Suffolk up the league up the
league tables in terms of delivery of
the first doses to the first four
cohorts
this work clearly isn't done however and
this week I've met with Ed Garrett from
our ccgs to ensure that we were working
as closely as possible with the NHS to
support the delivery of the vaccine
together we will be targeting our
resources and getting to the minority
that qualify but have not yet received
their Jab
it is also fantastic to see new
asymptomatic a symptomatic testing site
being rolled out in Stone Market which
will shortly be followed by even more
local sites too
I'm also really proud that we've been
able to extend our council tax hardship
scheme to further help the most
vulnerable in our district who have been
most impacted by covid
finally in terms of again in terms of
covid I'm sure we'll all be glued to the
TV on Monday to hear the PM outline the
government's plans for leading us out of
this lockdown there are lots of reasons
to be hopeful but in the meantime I
would like to reiterate our Suffolk wide
messages that Suffolk needs you to
follow the guidance hands face space to
get tested regularly if you are unable
to work from home and to get your covid
jab when it's your turn
in return Suffolk supports you through
home but not alone and our community
involvement the distribution of business
guard business grants self-isolation
payments and practical support for those
most in needs
I mentioned the snow earlier and
although it has now melted away I wanted
to pay tribute to our bin Crews who were
back out within 48 hours including
working on Saturday making Collections
and clearing the backlog as best they
could despite the weather we are
currently two to three days behind and
so unfortunately the delays will run
into early next week even with working
on Saturday again
as you know this was particularly
difficult since we have covered related
staff absences within the team which has
caused the garden Waste Service to be
suspended for now
I'm hopeful that I will be able to give
more positive news on this in the coming
weeks ahead of spring as the number of
positive cases continues to fall and
colleagues exit self-isolation
as it is half term I also wanted to
highlight the Fantastic initiative we
have in place
building on what we did during the
winter half term to tackle holiday
hunger
this scheme involves food Parcels
containing ingredients for five meals
for a family of four distributed to
families during half term
the initiative delivered on behalf of
the council by abbeycroft leisures
explore outdoor team ensures no child
goes hungry when free School meals are
paused during the school holidays
families in need are identified by local
schools and the food Parcels also
include ideas on how to make food
stretch further in future making a real
difference to the lives of low-income
families in our district
I also wanted to say a couple of words
in relation to Gateway 14. I will not
say too much as of course we wear many
hats in relation to this site including
being the planning Authority
I'm really pleased to see however that
the planning application has been
submitted
I also wanted to make all councilors
aware that officers together with their
development partner J Nick are meeting
on a four-weekly basis with a newly
formed residence group
finally I was of course really pleased
to be able to lend our support to
Gateway 14 being part of the wider
Freeport eastbid to government alongside
colleague councils businesses and our
MPS in Suffolk and Essex we will be
continuing to Lobby government and
keeping our fingers crossed that will be
one of the 10 freeports that will be
announced
thank you very much chair
thank you councilor Morley does anybody
have any questions for councilor Morley
we could see uh comes to Passmore please
um thank you very much chairman
um Susie thank you very much for your
report I'm sure you would um join with
me and perhaps the chairman of the
council in expressing our huge thanks
and um admiration for all those involved
in such a stellar performance and the
vaccine rollout program including people
who work for this Council as well I
think it's been a superhuman effort and
it does give us the key to unlocking our
future for the whole population I think
they've done a tremendous job and I
think they are to be absolutely
congratulated thank you absolutely thank
you councilor Passmore
um when I met with
um Ed Garrett
from our ccg earlier on this week
um he did tell me that despite the snow
across Suffolk we vaccinated 57
000 people in one week
and there was no let up in spite of the
snow they still got through everybody
that was due to be vaccinated last week
and I'm enormously grateful to
everything that our NHS and our ccgs are
doing
and I'm very happy to support them in
any way we can
thank you remarkable thank you
thank you councilor Passmore councilor
Mansell please
uh thank you chair I've got a couple of
questions for the leader if if that's uh
if that's okay uh firstly
um uh having uh been asked to
um support the covert vaccination
transport program with some of my
locality budget I just wondered whether
there was any report about how that was
progressing uh my second question
um I would like to know why um there is
no written
um document of your Leader's report in
the late papers thank you
personally
uh there is no written report because
there is no requirement for a written
report this is my announcements and in
order to get you the most accurate and
up-to-date information
it's being crafted
until the last possible moment it will
appear on our website as soon as is
practically
um
available
with regard to the community Transport
uh we have contacted over 150 Community
organizations in order to assess the
requirements and the needs for this only
two have come back to us and we're we're
working with them and we will continue
to work uh with the community groups as
they uh as we identify them
thank you and moving on to councilor
geek please
thank you chair
um thank you very much for your report
councilor Morley
um it is distressing to know that
welfare support for families is
insufficient for them to feed themselves
so although it's good to hear that food
boxes are being given out and excellent
that the families are being identified
by schools really of course it shouldn't
be needed and can you give us an idea of
how many families are in this situation
across the district
as
no I can't give you that figure at the
moment but we I'm happy to send it out
later
thank you
thank you uh councilor eberne please
thank you chair thank you councilor
Morley for those announcements um I've
got two questions if I may um you
mentioned
um sort of minorities that are difficult
to reach with regards to vaccinations
and I just wondered um what the council
specifically was doing to help reach
them and secondly
um with regards to the suspension of the
the Brown waste the garden waste bins
there have been a couple of suspensions
and residents have received money off
their bill
um for the next the coming year if there
are further
um suspensions will they be getting
further funds off their Bill thank you
very much
so I can answer the last one easiest so
um the same process will be in place to
ensure that nobody's paying for service
that they're not receiving so I can
confirm that
um just remind me what the what the
first one was
um just with regards to what the council
is doing you mentioned hard to reach
minorities for the vaccination program
and that the council was doing working
with the ccg for on that and I just
wanted what was what was the council's
role in that thank you Jeff
we have a regular outbreak engagement
board meetings with the ccgs and where
they identify particular areas or
particular cohorts that are uh not
coming forward then we're working with
them to to see how we can help and if
it's a community Transport issue then we
will we will help where we can
thank you very much thank you chair
thank you uh councilor Wellen please
thank you Chad uh thank you
um councilor Morley for your
announcements
and particularly to the reference of the
for the Gateway 14 residence group could
you tell us what's the makeup of the
residence group and how will members be
kept informed of relevant discussions
and agreements our representatives from
Villages and settlements close to the
site and particularly from Cedars Park
included in the group
I would have hoped that star Upland
would have been represented but I
haven't been informed that they are
could you clarify please
I'm happy to clarify that outside the
meeting
thank you
foreign
boys please
thank you chair thank you councilor
Lawley
um with regard to the uh free put are we
giving them
our unqualified support uh further on in
our papers today we talk about
environment social and governments
governance issues arising from our
investments Gateway 14 is our big
what about major Investments uh
could explain how these issues have been
addressed with regard to the freeports
sorry which issues were they these are
environment social and government
governance issues there are a a
important part of how we look at our
investments whether in fact their
environmentally sustainable
where the socially responsible and
whether we have
um proper governance over them
I'm not aware that we have any of those
issues at the moment I think it's we're
not that far Advanced but um
this is why I was asking about whether
we are giving unqualified support to the
Freeport or whether we are qualifying
our support
uh because
of environment social and governance
concerns Freeport
if I may jump in I think we're going
into a lot of depth and to Ambush
somebody and expect them to have all
that information at hand I think would
be really difficult I'd be grateful if
this could be taken offline and those
answers given to you
I would consent with that I didn't mean
to Ambush anyone no no it's fine it's
just in the opening comments it's a lot
of information and uh and In fairness I
don't think she would have that at hand
and I think we can take this outside of
the meeting
thank you thank you
are there any other questions for the
leader please
thank you in that case thank you
councilor Morley
we'll now move on to receive
notifications or petitions in accordance
with the council procedure rules
unreceived chair
thank you and moving on questions by the
public in accordance with Council
procedure rules and received chair okay
and now we'll move to the questions by
counselors in accordance with the
council procedure rules
um I refer you to the questions that are
from councilors in the table papers and
if a Cadance ask the counselors that are
asking the questions to please read out
that question in full for the benefit of
those that are listening or watching uh
this meeting who haven't got the
facility to read the table papers that'd
be really appreciated so we're going to
move on to question one which is from
councilor Stringer to councilor Fleming
Council for Stringer please
thank you chair given the Justified
public outcry of this Council cutting
down three of the walnut trees planted
by my former head teacher Mike carbon in
Walnut Tree walk in stone market and the
council subsequently stating incorrectly
that this was because mid-suffolk County
councils demanded their removal within
21 days when will the council offer an
apology and admit it was wrong
Council Fleming
yes good good evening everyone good
evening
um councilor Stringer
um
the district and I on behalf of the
district have made a public statement in
the East anglian recently which makes it
clear that the council regrets
the loss of these trees and I too
personally regret the loss of the three
walnut trees which were cut down on
Walnut Tree close following
miscommunications
and what appears to have been errors of
judgment on site the details of which
all have been publicly reported
mistakes happen
as all of us know and this was one of
them important lessons have been learned
and measures are being put in place to
avoid any similar error in the future
as Cabinet member for environment
including public realm I am sorry that
this happened and realize that the trees
were planted by a former Headmaster of
the Middle School the council intends to
make as much amends as it can by
ensuring that healthy and well-located
replacement trees are planted as soon as
feasible as part of the agreed planning
conditions
thank you um Kelsey Stringer do you have
a supplementary question yes I do thank
you very much can I thank councilor
Fleming for for saying the word sorry uh
in in that speech publicly uh that that
helps me certainly to draw a line uh and
move on uh which I I really hope to do
uh would councilor Fleming agree that
now it would be whether it be a good
idea to actually rethink our proposals
in in the site we own in Walnut Tree
walk uh to make sure we are uh bringing
back better than we've taken away and
then communicate that widely to the
public in the area so we we avoid these
mistakes in the future thank you chair
um
sorry I'm I'm not sure that anything I
can say about this particular site will
help avoid anything in the future I
think the new procedures we've put in
place will however in terms of this
particular site as councilor Stringer
knows the um site is scheduled for
redevelopment for housing and
the
area along the close where the trees
were cut is actually
that road is unfortunately going to be
widened and the trees that were cut down
as far as I can tell from looking at
plans would have had to have been
removed anyway and the planning
application which was determined earlier
last year
um past muster with about four or five
objections and the plans have already
been approved as I understand I don't
believe there is anything that I or
anyone else can do to revisit planning
conditions that have already been
through the planning process
um I think that's all I can say about it
thank you Council Fleming councilor
Stringer moving on now to question two
which is from councilor Mansell to
councilor burn please councilor Mansell
uh thank you chair
um my question uh is to councilor Byrne
the healthy homes act calls for a set of
healthy homes principles to be made law
and as such part of national planning
policy since advising officers of this
initiative in January we have not heard
anything more will this Council support
the healthy homes Act
thank you councilor Byrne please
uh thank you very much
confidential
um
the homes we live in have a major impact
on our health and well-being
and this council is committed to
delivering healthy new homes through our
emerging joint local plan
the Town and Country planning
association's important campaign to
introduce new legislation in the form of
a healthy homes act includes laudable
aims and objectives which we are already
seeking to implement insofar as is
possible under current national policy
it is not yet certain how the government
May seek to implement and standardize
the principles proposed by the Town and
Country Planning Association Talent
County Planning Association
so we do not know what the design and
cost impacts would be on development in
our area
but I welcome the Town and County
Planning association's efforts and this
Council will continue to push for near
healthy new homes
I will ask monitors officers to monitor
the progress of this campaign and any
subsequent Bill through parliament in
order that we can respond to changes at
the national level and identify but best
practice for implementing The Joint
local plan
thank you
thank you customers so do you have a
supplementary question uh yes yes if I
may I think it's it's very pleasing to
hear from councilor burn that we are
incorporating uh many um features within
the joint local plan to make sure that
our the homes that are built in this
District are are as healthy as possible
um but but would it be possible for this
Council to actually incorporate some of
those exemplary
um
exemplary uh features
um to ensure the healthy homes are in
some of our own developments
castleburn in advance of it becoming
um you know adopted as law
um thank you um
I I think we do presently look just to
see what how how far we can actually
extend our um uh implementation of uh
these particular standards and we do try
to optimize as as much as possible
um I think this will be as as design
becomes more and more at to the
Forefront of um of planning which it
certainly is going to do I think
um
I I think I can reassure you that that
the likelihood is that the standards
that we will be able to achieve in
future will be will be higher but
certainly it's a laudable aim and um I I
share I share your uh uh hope for it
you're muted Barry
right I'm hopefully back now
thank you okay the next question is from
counselor Austin to councilor Morley
councilor Austin please
thank you chairman
uh this Council agreed to establish a
youth Council as part of the green
liberal Democrat amendment in 2020.
this current year as a result of the
pandemic has been extremely difficult
for young people physically and mentally
the youth council could help to
establish just what the most important
issues are for them and to start to put
in place some of those issues identified
what has the council done to implement
this commitment
councilor Morley please
thank you chair
as part of the
2020-21 budget setting the green and
liberal Democrat group presented 10 key
proposals to the administration
he was agreed that some of these
proposals will be progressed when the
council approved the budget
Administration places a great deal of
importance in engaging all citizens in
democracy including young people however
it was felt that a youth Council wasn't
the only option to achieving this
therefore officers have been working on
research and a scoping document for a
wider project on Democratic engagement
this work has been delayed due to during
the kovi 19 pandemic the staff have been
redeployed to Priority response tasks
but will recommence in May 2021 I can
assure you that I personally and this
Administration place the utmost
importance on the well-being of all our
citizens you can see this from our
vision and strategic priorities
we know from National statistics that
this pandemic has had a particular
effect on the mental health and
well-being of younger people and we
continue to work with our partners
across the system to provide support for
them
thank you chair
thank you councilor council do you have
a supplementary question well you know
yes chairman I'm very disappointed to
hear
um Council Morris respond to this
um I think it's very disappointing that
we've had no indication of exactly what
work is being done and I would hope that
what she's saying is that the proposal
to implement a youth Council has now
been put on hold and I believe that we
need to hear from her exactly what is
being planned and to have detailed of
any time scale of where that plans is
happening thank you very much councilman
if you'd like to respond please I'm not
sure that that's actually a question
I've just said it will recommence in May
2021 I can't tell you any more than that
at the moment
okay thank you
so we'll now move to question four which
is counselor Matthew sent to councilor
Byrne please councilor mathiason please
thank you chair what information do you
have to give confidence that our housing
delivery and our build pipeline will
continue to justify a five-year housing
loan Supply
councilor burn
thank you chair
um
thank you for the question councilor
Mathison
um mid-suffolk District Council
currently has a housing land supply of
7.67 years as shown in the housing land
Supply position statement uh of October
2020.
the council also passed the government's
annual housing delivery test with the
result of 103 percent for the 2020 tests
published in January 2021
we also maintain an up-to-date housing
delivery Test action plan which has been
through overview and scrutiny committee
The Joint local plan identifies a supply
of development from April 2018 up to
March 2037
and minimum housing requirement areas
for the Earth
minimum housing requirement figures for
those areas producing the neighborhood
plan
in order to maintain a consistent and
favorable Supply and delivery of
development throughout the plan period
the policies aim to identify and create
flexibility for sufficient Housing
Development and a buffer of
approximately 20 percent in the supply
of new land has been identified
if there is any concern if I have any
concern around our land Supply
it is around the issue that it's
important that we continue to Grant
planning permissions that will enable us
to maintain and top up Supply
do you have a supplementary question
please
yes I I think the um
I can't see that the
um that we should continue to Grant
planning permissions when when we know
we've got something like seven thousand
that we've already approved um the it's
encouraging that the delivery test was
most recently okay but I think we still
need to know frequently how that is
going
um you know October's we've now four
months away
in the past
are we still are we still are we still
holding
have you got a question yeah are we you
know do we know that we are actually
still up at seven seven years
um three months later I mean there's
been a lot of stops and starts in the in
the building industry
Castleberry please
yeah well it's you're asking asking me
crystal ball stuff uh Council Matheson
um
we have no indications that that that's
that healthy 7.67 years has slipped
significantly over the past uh over the
past three months
as as and when we fixed the um
the five year land Supply figure
um
no we will not not be recalculating it
every month just to check that we're
still managing to stay on the right side
of five years
um I think I think we can be fairly
confident that at the moment we are um
still within that figure well within
that figure and the business about
um uh granting permissions you have to
remember that whilst we have a certain
level of control over the development
delivery of housing uh the greater part
of that control is over it is held by
the Developers
and so we're entirely in their hands as
to whether
um whether it is delivered by them
um that is why it's important that we
continue to maintain a supply of
permissions so that any any which do
drop off the end because they're not
developed insufficient time uh and their
their permissions lapse we nonetheless
maintain our numbers
thank you thank you councilors uh moving
to question six councilor Pratt
um question two councilor Fleming
councilor Pratt please
thank you very much chair
um so this question really comes off the
back of the um the recent um recycling
campaign
um from from constituents or residents
basically um so the council halted the
collection of tetra pack when the
current mrf contract began in May 2019
and one of the reasons cited
um for this is that um Tetra pack only
makes up
around one percent of mrf with uh waste
inputs
um it was also explained by our officers
that it is technically difficult to
separate tetrapak materials from mixed
recyclers
due to the automated recovery processes
being used there and that sorting uh
Tetra pack from recycler is um really
uneconomical to do by hand
um nonetheless
um over 90 percent of local authorities
are now collecting cartons for recycling
and more than 65 of local authorities
need to just Cycles
Council partnership in so you raised the
question it's in the table papers I'd
like to read that question that's all
right
no just with the question just read the
question
right well
I think it's important to point out that
local authorities in Norfolk and
Cambridge here collects cartons from the
curbside residence
um from from recycling bins
and and most and many in Essex also do
the same so my question is how are other
local authorities separating Tetra pack
from other recyclers and why are we not
doing the same here
thank you uh councilor Fleming please
yes thank you for your question
um councilor Pratt
um yes some other local authorities are
still accepting cartons or Tetra packs
and this is through a mix of curbside
collection household waste recycling
centers and bring sites however curbside
collections particularly in local
authorities where the recyclers are
mixed as they are in Suffolk
um are YG being phased out
if you go to the Tetra pack company
website and ask where to recycle their
product you will be directed to a site
in your area in our case you'll be
directed to the Stow Market household
waste recycling center
you are not directed to your bin
according to best information most local
authorities in England
are taking the approach of ceasing
curbside collection
Essex still accepts
tetrapack but this is a function of its
um the age of its waste contract as was
ours and it's expected that when they
renew theirs it will be different
the cartons are considered actually as
contaminants
most new waste recycling contracts
exclude cartons slash Tetra packs and
I'm not sure if you knew this but it is
now illegal to include carton residue in
recycled paper for export
although Suffolk local authorities do
collect them at the at this at the bring
sites it is not cost effective and
Suffolk councils pay a company called
Ace UK to have them removed
h2k is a related organization to
tetrapak UK
in Warrington
there they are broken down and separated
into a fiber which can be incorporated
into paper products and a plastic
aluminum mix which is problematic in
terms of its reuse
this is in contrast to other recyclable
materials which there's a positive
market value and an income stream back
to the council and I might add in
addition to texture backs coffee pods
pose a similar dilemma as they are also
a composite material and although
technically recyclable are in effect to
contaminant
and are best disposed in the black bin
were taken to rehearsal waste recycling
center
thank you
does the chair need to come in next
my apology is trying to get the mute
button off um yeah do you have a
supplementary question
and well the supplementary
um
may as well be well I made a bit of a
hash off of this to be honest when I
sent it in um I was supposed to ask the
second question as a supplementary in
the supplementary
um as a second question but yeah um well
I I guess the answer is going to be no
but would you raise this issue with the
Suffolk waste partnership and jointly
investigate how other local authorities
are sorting the tetrapak material from
other recyclers
um well as a member of the Suffolk West
partnership we do discuss tetrabax quite
a lot because
um a lot of residents are upset that
Tetra packs which are widely used and a
very useful item
um
are not readily recite recyclable
um but the Suffolk waste partnership
along with other local Authority bodies
nationally
have raised the problem posed by
Composite Materials such as this to
central government which is in
discussion with active discussion with
the packaging container industry to seek
ways to improve the capacity to recycle
their products while retaining their
usefulness
so that's my response to that
thank you and uh Council thank you for
clearing up the confusion yeah I
understand I understand what went wrong
um so I guess that is your supplementary
question correct well
um
yeah that was the supplementary question
for question one in effect yes so there
is no question to confirmed
um no good thank you thank you for being
honest and uh thank you councilor uh for
your questions and Council Fleming for
your response
you're welcome
okay we're now moving on so we're going
to move to mc20 24 general fund budget
for 2021 2022 and a four-year Outlook
I'd like to invite councilor Whitehead
to introduce the paper mc20 24 and to
move the recommendations in the reports
as this is a complex paper I am minded
to allow councilor Whitehead and
councilor field and their second is
longer than the time normally allowed
which is generally five minutes under
these circumstances all of the
counselors will have three minutes now
all our extended the period
um you know we're not talking hours so
we still need to be concise and clear
councilor Whitehead
oh thank you Mr chairman actually before
I turn to the budget before you start a
clock on my speech anyway because I just
take literally one minute to express my
sincere thanks to the finance team that
has pulled together these complex and
detailed budgets in truly unconventional
circumstances
with so many of our Council staff
working from home with remote meetings
remote file sharing with so many also
taking on home teaching roles it may
seem unfair to just single out the
finance team when there are clearly
Heroes throughout the entire
organization
however it's been my long experience
that back office Finance stuff are
really recognized for the vital role
they play they don't grab headlines they
don't make photo shoots or win Awards
and accordingly some may regard
themselves as merely small cogs and some
giant mechanism but they are not all of
them play an important role that keeps
this vital Public Service organization
functioning properly so we're on behalf
of this Administration I trust the whole
cohort of counselors I'd like to say a
really big thank you to the entire
Finance team for all their Sterling
efforts in such difficult circumstances
your points are noted and your time
begins now okay thank you though wait a
minute sorry I
get the right document up now right okay
turn into my budget speech thank you and
pleased to introduce this year's budget
report mc2024
this year the government has rightly
focused its attention on the fight
against covid-19 getting us through this
deadly pandemic and devising very
generous Financial packages for
residents businesses and local
authorities
at one stage last year I could see us
needing to use a significant part of our
accumulated reserves just for survival
that survival was never in doubt but as
the cast we would emerge significantly
weaker
but general generous central government
assistance means they've absorbed most
of that pain
the downside though to all this is that
the government has only announced a
one-year settlement
the three-year comprehensive spending
review has been delayed as has the fair
funding review business rates review and
a business rates reset we wait to see
what new scheme emerges from the
consultation on new homes bonus
replacement
so the future before Beyond March 2022
is succinctly uncertain our projections
do look real easy but we can't be sure
so turning to the immediate year ahead
of us even the inherent uncertainties
going forward we are again recommending
a 1.66 increase in mid-suffolk's share
of the council tax
I always trust that residents when they
see the payments Mississippi on their
bank statements will appreciate that we
as the district council actually retain
less than 10 percent of the total we
collect from them well the 90 is passed
on to County the police and town of
Parish councils
so for ourselves we are just asking for
two pound 80 a year more for a Bandy
house that's less than one penny per day
for a Bandy house it's only 18 Pence a
month a ban C 21 Pence a month and a
band d23 Pence a month and approximately
two-thirds of all our houses fall into
those three bands
so I do understand why some District
councils have chosen to freeze their
council tax this year but this modest
increase of a few Pence per month
generates 104 000 for the council and we
will put it to good use that amount 104
000 is going into a ring fenced covered
business Recovery Fund to help our local
businesses first recover and then Thrive
once again
so let me turn now to other income
within the budget our pooled fund
investments will bring in 566 000 pounds
a very useful sum
sifco should be fully invested by the
31st of March this year and with no
further Investments planned beyond that
date we will be able to access Public
Works loans board funding for all our
other needs going forward
now I readily acknowledge that cifco has
generated its share of adverse media
articles and letters but the completed
civco fund will bring it in one million
five hundred and fourteen thousand of
net interest to miss Suffolk in 2122
that's the equivalent of
8823 additional bandi houses or 24 of
our existing housing stock
we've taken out capital and interest
repayment loans so over time that let
interest will act slowly but surely
increase as the capital is repaid
sifco is real income coming into our
district from outside of it a large
number of outer District business
tenants are funding our Vital Public
Services local public services and cifco
will still be funding those services for
years to come
sifco is the gift that will keep on
giving and I do trust that the majority
of our residents clearly understand that
but there is one source of income in our
budget that I feel is how can I put an
accounting Quirk and that's a 1.631
million pounds of Interest receivable on
the large loan extended to Gateway 14.
and until that development gets underway
there will be no cash flow we have to
book it for accounting reasons but
there's no cash to spend
to reflect this reality that wholesome
has been put into the commercial
development risk management reserve and
we'll spend it when the project comes
good and the cash starts to flow
I'll turn now to other reserves we're
putting a quarter million pound into a
planning legal Reserve to ensure we can
support our local residents by robustly
defending Appeals and 50 000 pounds to
finance planning enforcement actions
where they are needed
we're also putting an additional half
million pounds towards climate change
and biodiversity
here at Mid Suffolk we are committed to
taking proper action in this vital area
of climate change for the sake of this
generation and for those to come
now our budget projections clearly show
that it's efficiently run Council can do
more than just tick over can do more
than just get by delivering statutory
Services we can face the uncertain
future with confidence we have truly
ambitious plans for our districts as we
emerge from covert we're therefore
creating four pots of funding with one
billion pound in each
extra money to fund economy housing
communities and well-being in
midsurfette we'll be truly thriving not
just surviving
along with the climate change and
biodiversity Reserve that's a total of
five million pounds we will be investing
in the future of our district
so we can look forward with real
confidence exciting times are ahead and
that future can start today with the
approval of the general fund budget the
four-year Outlook and therefore
delighted to propose a recommendations
set out in paragraphs 3.1 to 3.4 and
would look for a second there thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead can I have
a second to please
counselor Morley
thank you chair
as as councilors know the administration
through councilor Whitehead skillful
stewardship have carefully managed
mid-suffolk's financial position over a
number of years
as a result we're now seeing the
benefits of this approach as mid-suffolk
has avoided many of the financial
challenges that other districts and
boroughs are currently facing
as described by councilor Whitehead we
already planned to continue to take a
prudent approach in a number of areas
including commercial development risk
business rates and with our planning
Reserves
but this is not a time to Simply Be
prudent
this is a time to be investing in our
district to ensure it doesn't just
swiftly bounce back from the devastating
impacts of the kovid pandemic but is
able to thrive
that we provide the bright and healthy
futures for our residents and
communities
as leader I want us to judge ourselves
by how how we look after the most
vulnerable in our district
with this in mind it is fantastic that
we are now able to supercharge our
investment into our district
this means not just investment in
tackling climate change and biodiversity
with another five hundred thousand but
building the affordable and sustainable
homes people need investment in people's
physical and mental health supporting
the recovery and growth of our local
economy and strengthening and enabling
civic pride Community spirit and
empowered local democracy
and investing all of our modest council
tax increase into more direct financial
support for those businesses who have
suffered most over the last 11 months
what councilor Whitehead has proposed
this evening sends a clear signal of
confidence and commitment to all our
residents and businesses
we have made it clear that we want to
invest in our residents and our
communities through our vision and
corporate plan adopted at the end of
2019 we have made it clear that our
strategic priorities are our communities
their well-being their housing our
environment our local economy and our
customers
we have clear strategies and delivery
plans in place for all of these apart
from well-being which is being developed
however the impact of covid requires us
to revisit all of these as the
conditions surrounding us and the
impacts being felt by our residents have
fundamentally changed
for example we are reviewing our housing
revenue account Council housing business
plan and we have already drafted a
revised covid economic recovery plan
we are of course still in lockdown and
we are not out of covidjet and so our
plans will need to remain flexible and
adapt
but there are reasons to be optimistic
and now is therefore the time to use our
financially strong position to invest
back into our communities and into our
economy to both stimulate and support
our Swift recovery
it is therefore fantastic to see that
councilor Whitehead proposing an
additional 4 million of funding for
investment in our local economy housing
the well-being of our residents and in
our communities
as I've already said in most cases the
delivery pans for each of these areas is
already in place and this funding will
enable us to expand and accelerate our
recovery
ultimately it is for cabinet to approve
these plans but I want all councilors in
a cross-party way to come together to
inform how best to Target this
additional investment to support
recovery in our district
in anticipation of approval of the
budget tonight I've asked officers to
develop a format to help aid these
cross-party discussions
for example through councilor workshops
or some other mechanism
there are five aspects that cabinet have
insisted that the offices include and
these are
that the funding be primarily focused on
accelerating recovery from covid for our
communities and businesses
that we should continue to work in
partnership with others and seek
external funding wherever possible we do
not want the availability of our funding
to result in us becoming insular in our
approach or to miss other opportunities
this must be an evidence-based approach
where the data and Analysis of that data
drives the decisions about how where and
when to invest this money
a holistic approach this is not about
separately looking at each of these five
earmarked funds but ensuring we are
delivering in a rounded way for all our
communities
all of our strategic priorities are
linked for example what we do in housing
has an impact on the environment and so
we need to do this in a joined up way
finally and most importantly this must
be a commissioning for outcomes approach
what this means in practice is that we
don't start with a list of projects
proposed by counselors we start with a
clear understanding of the needs of our
residents and what we are trying to
achieve
we have articulated these clearly in the
corporate plan and each of our key
strategies
the task therefore using the evidence
and working holistically is to determine
the activity to best deliver the
outcomes they and we want to see
I expect to have further details of the
mechanisms for this cross-party working
from officers within the next few weeks
what I do want to do this evening though
as leader of the council is to clearly
set out the kind of map the kind of
impact that I and my group want to see
delivered
this is not however an exhaustive list
we want to see the inequalities exposed
and exacerbated by covid being
eradicated
we want to end food and fuel poverty we
want to end homelessness and rough
sleeping we want to end isolation and
see good mental health nurtured and
sustained
and we want to be rid of domestic abuse
and all forms of hate and abuse this new
investment will now allow us to go
further and faster in not just tackling
or minimizing these negative social
issues but properly resolving and
removing them permanently
we are supporting and enhancing our
communities to build bright and healthy
futures for all our residents and
communities
thank you chair
thank you councilor Morley councilor
food I believe you wish to propose the
Amendments from the green and liberal
Democratic group
I do indeed thank you
maintenance
seeks to deliver for the people of
Mid-South Africa and some of the issues
they continuously rise
and to accelerate delivery on promises
we have all made
it also responds to the pandemic
it focuses in part on the vital
environmental issues we must address as
our response to the climate emergency
but covers Economic Development as well
it's deliberately cautious taking some
limited advantage of the budget surplus
and the current energy related woundfall
we've assought an amendment where we
hope we will to be able to work together
with substantial emphasis on developing
and understanding of what is possible on
our issues and determine what level of
action and funding is sensible and
possible
in several areas we're posing
exploratory work with indicative amounts
of possible spend in the 2012 23.
our proposal which is detailed in the
papers is in five elements
measures to meet our community's needs
and concerns on planning and development
a supplementary planning document to
seek affordable retail development to
help economic recovery
action to ensure progress is made at a
pace to ensure that everyone has healthy
secure and warm housing
a supplementary planning document for
biodiversity enhancement and for our
active travel
and four measures to coordinate
activities on AG production storage and
usage develop a councilwide strategy on
that subject
elements focused on supporting
challenges took home communities are
additional funding to the cab at 50k per
year
we all value the high quality lousy
voluntary help and guidance the CIB
provides to help people out of their
difficulties particularly in areas such
as debt
the pandemic clearly increases the need
and reduces funding we must ensure that
they can deliver to avoid knock-on
Demand on Council services and the
obvious impact on people's lives
we wish to support full banks serving
Suffolk with grants of 50K
there are many out of work and those now
on furlough are highly likely to lose
jobs shortly
many are forced to turn to food banks
perhaps for the first time ever and this
grant although not massive would
significantly boast
default Banks resources
we use improvements to the political
engagement by young people you've heard
that already tonight
we have proposed again a youth Council
to give young people encouragement to
engage with our District's governance
to give them the feeling that their
opinions matter and the opportunities to
discern in some actions that really
matter to them
in the planning area a major focus of
our business we propose action on
enforcement to the value of 154k we wish
to enable officers to improve response
on planning enforcement we are
persistently reminded that it is
essential that developers large and
small complied with the requirements
placed upon them
this must be enforced by well-resourced
team with only reasonable concerned on
legal spend
it would improve the council's image
achieve the control we all wish and
reduce the tendency for people to take
Liberties when they know they will not
be challenged
on viability we propose 10K a small sum
actually but we propose a viability
claims are examined as far as possible
in public with counselors at least aware
of the detail it's essential that our
read residents have confidence in this
process and the calculations are not of
mechanism for reducing delivery on
social benefits to the community
on preamp advice another ten thousand we
propose that the availability of free
pre-ar bias to community groups is
enhanced
this would address an impediment to
community-led products
projects any reduction in the need for
upfront funding will increase delivery
reduce the feeling of deliberate
obstruction to that's up groups perhaps
unjustly suffer
Gateway 14 we're proposing a 25
000 plus another hundred recognizing the
gate for A14 is managed by a separate
company we propose a community liaison
group to be set up to develop and secure
benefit Community benefits in a way that
makes progress visible and to be
responsive to the community pleased to
say I think you've already moved on that
one economy and the employment to resist
to assist the retail sector to recover
from its current challenge not just the
covid-19 disaster but also the channel
shift that has accelerated we proposed
two retail incubators a small expansion
of the successful Innovation Center
activity
the response to climate change in the
environment we produce 40K on housing we
need to encourage learning and early
progress in the vital reduction of heat
loss and the switch to carbon-free heat
sources we propose we found an officer
who can research and provide expert
trusted advice and guidance combined
with leadership and support for those
who must in regard bark on change
in Gateway 14 Landscaping we proposed
the 100K investment in Advanced
Landscaping to ensure benefits to Stone
Market Community occur as the project
progresses not decades later
and on trees finally we propose an
additional tree officer to enable
proactive maintenance of trees on
council's own land and to prevent the
continuation of the recent Spate of
incidents that we heard about earlier
that of course public against an
incorrect view that mid-suffer does not
care
on energy production and storage finally
perhaps 100K revenue and 30k plus
Capital grants from external sources uh
last but no means least to say we
propose additional investment in the
vital energy storage uh production usage
area we're proposing additional Staffing
to accelerate our progress in this
Christian career a study of the
significant areas like hydrogen
production storage and usage
we've included a small Capital allow our
location to help accelerate the
provision of electric cars charging
we would like to see progress towards a
facility like that recently introduced
by private funding in Essex
we should recognize that gateway14 will
introduce a major demand particularly if
it does become an element of the high
even Gateway Freeport which we all look
forward to
but thank you for your intention and say
please support our Amendment thank you
castlefield thank you
um do you have a second
Council of War bonus Council War boys
please
thank you chair I'm very happy to Second
these amendments to the general field
uh general fund budget
I would like to stress that these five
amendments are in support of mid-suffolk
District council's Six strategic
priorities
secondly these amendments are supported
in this council's goal in responding to
the climate emergency and achieving net
carbon Zero by 2030. also that they have
been scrutinized by the section 151
officer and are achievable without
compromising the setting of a balanced
budget nor resulting in any increase to
council tax or rents
these amendments are above all specific
positive responses to the difficult
times ahead for our communities and our
recognition that this is a time to
invest in our communities and if
necessary draw on Reserves
we look forward to further improve the
council standing with our communities by
supporting additional planning
enforcement and further training of our
development committee members we
recognize the growing need for financial
support for food banks and the citizens
advice Bureau
we're either green and liberal Democrats
want to see more participation in our
democratic system and are continuing to
support setting up of a youth Council
following on from the council's success
is supporting The Innovation Center as
an employment incubator we propose
helping to revitalize our high streets
by creating two retail incubators
for Gateway 14 we consider that now is
the time to work with Community groups
to deliver a community resource on site
as more planning details emerge for
Gateway 14 we consider that now is a
time to initiate a program a structural
Landscaping to achieve mature and
attractive green spaces on first
occupation
Gateway 14's development brief
anticipates that buildings will
incorporate green energy
so as response to this and the
government's white paper of December
2020 we consider that the time is right
to fund a feasibility study exploring
the possibilities of establishing the
energy storage system on the Gateway 14
system
this would be a vital element in
developing a local strategy for energy
production storage and use
finally energy related data management
will be critical to a local
epsu strategy
so we also proposed working with
Partners such as Innovation labs to
research and model a digital energy
infrastructure
the future is almost upon us to achieve
net carbon zero we will need to
coordinate energy needs across the
council's assets
these amendments are deliberate steps
towards that goal thank you
thank you councilor War boys
councilor at Whitehead do you accept the
amendment or any elements of it
thank you chair if I may respond even
before councilor field and Council of
War boys very detailed speeches I could
clearly see that the opposition has
invested a lot of time and diligence in
pulling together their budget amendment
paper it's certainly a therapiece of
work
it's over prescriptive in parts I mean
as counselors we should set out our
desired results and outcomes then leave
it to our chief executive officer to
determine the requisite Staffing but
with any minor exceptions I do emphasize
with the girls outlined and Mr chairman
I'm very conscious it was only at last
Monday's cabinet meeting that I first
announced these additional 4 million for
one million pound pots of money to be
allocated for economy housing
communities and well-being that's a
tremendous amount of money and this
Administration doesn't have the
arrogance or hubris to think that only
we know best how to spend it we'd like
to approach this not in some diversive
or bipartisan way but rather to come
together in a cross-party way and set up
cross-party discussions
and with the genuine promise offered by
our leader in Her seconding speech which
is now clearly on the record I would
like to ask the opposition if they are
prepared to withdraw these amendments
and either support or at least abstain
on the budget before us this evening and
then join us in cross-party workshops
and other mechanisms as we go forward
and spend these significant sums of
money for the real benefit of all our
residents Mr chairman it's my sincere
hope that they will
and if it helps in consideration of our
offer I'd be happy to have some
additional words to the recommendations
3.1 to give them further Comfort around
our offer please do
okay I mean I was just a a three point
one as it stands but then which
basically says propose the general fund
uh and four-year Outlook be approved and
that recommendations to Cabinet be
prepared using a balanced cross-party
approach for the allocation of the
additional four million pound of funding
for investment in our local economy
housing the well-being of our residents
and in our communities this cross-party
approach would also give consideration
to the budget amendments proposed in
both 2021 and now in for 2122 thank you
thank you we'll get the offices to take
those words down
um councilor field and Council of War
boys do you wish to withdraw your
amendments
can I just say you know that we
certainly have no wish to indulge in in
pointless
conflict between the two halves of our
Council
um there clearly is a broad area of
agreement although they're clearly also
are matters of principle where we
disagree
but uh a genuine offer to indulge in
cross-party work
um is always welcome and uh certainly
the the statements from councilor
Whitehead and from the leader appear to
be just that we're certainly prepared to
take that on trust I think and therefore
I'm prepared to withdraw
um our amendment I have to emphasize we
really need to deliver and we don't want
to find any years time that we we have
just delivered promises we want real
tangible things that people can see on
that basis I will be prepared to
withdrawal
thank you and Council of War boys
thank you Chet um
I think I welcome the the offer of
um genuine cross-party work to deliver
on the council strategic priorities
a second Council feels remarks
particularly the need to deliver
uh I think
as I said the future is upon us there is
a genuine urgency to invest in our
communities so these cross-party
parties works towards that I'm happy to
support them
Council War boys thank you
um councilor Whitehead before we move on
can you just uh read out the words that
have changed the amendment please that
you're going to suggest that go in sure
so 3.1 on a gender item 8 will read that
the general fund budget proposals for
2122 and four-year Outlook set out in
the report be approved and that
recommendations to Cabinet be prepared
using a balanced cross-party approach
for the allocation of the additional
four million pound of funding for
investment in our local economy housing
the well-being of our residents and in
our communities this cross-party
approach will also give consideration to
the budget amendments proposed in 2021
and for 2122 and I said just like to put
on record my thanks for to councilors
field and War boys for
their agreement
thank you uh councilor Morley do you
accept the additional wording to
recommendation 3.1 as just stated
uh yes thank you chair I do it I do
accept the change to the wording and I
would also like to Echo my thanks to
councilor's field and War boys
thank you
thank you uh unless there are any
objections I will take this as the
meetings consensus I'll just give you a
couple of seconds
okay in that case we'll go straight to
the questions debate on the substantive
motion as amended uh we're now going to
move on to questions counselors may ask
as many questions as you wish however
they must be relevant to the subject and
discussion and must be formed as a
question
Stringer please
thank you chair uh councilor Whitehead
uh in in the speech that you just gave
did you suggest that us working on this
new proposal would be based on us either
abstaining
or voting for The substantive motion
um I think
I think to be realistic I I wouldn't
want to suggest you might support
um I mean I think if I put myself in
your position I think um yeah this is
the administration's budget you are the
opposition so I think um that's why the
offer is you can support if you want but
I mean to me I have staining and sort of
saying well it's our budget but we'd
like to come aboard and and work with
you going forward would be more than
acceptable to myself
I hope that answers your question
actually no it didn't oh
um
your words seem to suggest that if we
were to vote against this there would be
a voting against
The Proposal I.E the working together in
the future that's certainly how I read
it
well I
I think um
to me
um uh it's almost sort of a sign of Good
Will we're saying let's not be divisive
let's work together in a in a positive
way going forward to me to sort of to
agree that and then literally minutes
later vote down the budget to me doesn't
seem to be in that same Spirit but you
know that's just my thoughts
Stringer
sorry chair I I have nothing more to add
the question was answered thank you
thank you uh councilor eberne please
um thank you very much chair and thank
you councilor Whitehead
um I've got two questions if I may
um and they're very specific budget ones
um so on at 8 17 under supplies and
services
um it refers to a 43 000 pound increase
in the service charge to Endeavor house
now we haven't been in Endeavor house
for the past year we don't know when
we're going to go back into it and many
organizations are negotiating service
charges and rents downwards so how come
we are expecting an increase that's my
first question thank you and my second
question is under 7.5
um when you detail out the reserves at
the end of um the next financial year
we'll still have 18 million pounds in
reserves and that's on top of the four
million pounds you're referring to so 22
million overall
um if the 4 million isn't spent during
the year so so taking that 18 million
um where are the plans in the budget to
show what that is going to be spent on
thank you chair
Council Washington
uh thank you
um in terms of your first question 8 17
um and the um budgeted 43 000 pound
increase in uh in the service charge for
endeavor house I mean this is literally
what it says it's a budgeted figure I
guess um when we first made these
Arrangements long fairly long-term relay
arrangements with Endeavor house and
Suffolk County Council we are
anticipating you know various increments
over time
um obviously the code has changed at a
great deal and I would think that the
County Council of sales must be saving
various service charge type
costs throughout this pandemic so I
would hope that when it came to
negotiation
well we would negotiate for an actual
figure and which I would hope would be
below that in the budget but literally
that figure there is just a budgeted
figure it's not a figure that necessary
will be spent and for all the reasons
you've clearly set out I would hope it
would reduce
so that's that first question second
question 7.5 and it's an extensive table
of forecasted earmark reserves and I
think um a critical word in that is the
word earmarked because some I guess
there's a product about 20 different
items down there obviously the growth
efficiency fund at the end of next year
is down to 371 000 commercial
development risk management is a a
growing amount
um four million and growing until such
time as Gateway 14 starts to generate
cash
um another big one on business rates and
Council collection I think is a vital
one there so I won't go down them all
but just to make the point that most of
those are earmarked reserved not just
the sort of total General type Reserve
I'm going to bring in Arthur who may be
able to answer with a bit more DC and
then I'd like to come back if I made
here thank you of course thank you
awesome thank you chairman I just
thought I might be able to help in
relation to councilor e Burns first
question regarding Endeavor house
um as councilor Whitehead said we are in
acting negotiations uh to see if we can
bring those service charges down I have
had uh correspondence today from the
County Council along exactly those lines
so I'm confident that will be possible
but I thought it would just be useful to
explain why it was budgeted to go up the
reason it was budgeted to go up
originally was because we actually
entered into a very good deal with
Suffolk County Council when we first
moved into the building and so we had a
discounted rate for the first few years
that discount is due to now expire which
is why it was budgeted to now increase
not because the charges are necessarily
increasing in terms of our usage purely
because we've come to the end of that
discount period of time but as I say we
have been able to have further
discussions uh with them nothing to do
with covert purely to do with what we
think is the right amount to be charging
or but in procurring rather in terms of
our space as members will also be aware
we are actively looking at how we can
reduce our space within Endeavor house
on top of the monies that's not budgeted
for because that's not been confirmed at
this stage but work is being explored
both in terms of relinquishing the
members area which I know several
councilors have indicated they would be
happy to do but equally exploring
whether it be possible to compress our
footprint within the building into one
of the two floor plates rather than the
two floor plates that we currently have
that's not guaranteed clearly we need to
see how covid pans out and equally have
a new way of working will be in the
future but it seems a sensible thing for
us to be exploring I just thought that'd
be helpful German
very helpful thank you uh Council Eben
thank you Taylor thank you um Arthur for
that explanation as well and so I can
take from that um councilor Whitehead
that that 43 000 might even go the other
way and we might be in positive
um and you know we did
um we did put four proposals over two
years ago now to reduce the space at
Endeavor house so I would hope that that
is taken to consideration and I'd look
forward to it will be very helpful I
think to all councilors councilor white
if we could have an update on that
because obviously that
um what the chief executive has just
discussed is obviously news to some
people so thank you very much for that
thank you yes I mean in all these things
I'd I like to over sorry under promise
and over deliver so I hope not to let
you down
thank you uh moving on to councilor
Mansell please
thank you chair
um I I
I'd like to ask our question about
um paragraph 710
um I I welcome the um further half a
million uh to be transferred to the
climate change biodiversity Reserve uh
which was established um in 20 2021
um and went alongside the climate change
task force who who
um made a list of proposals um and there
are a number of projects that um were
incorporated into the council's carbon
reduction management plan uh and I
wondered which of those actual projects
are being funded from this um directly
from the one million pound budget which
we've now going to have for climate
change
um and um I realized that you may not be
able to answer that here and now but I'd
like to hear what you're saying then I'd
like to come back with another question
if that's all right okay please do well
I certainly don't have that detail just
a hand but one thing I would say is we
we put this we've put money into
reserves and then our excellent staff go
out and get grants for outside sources
so instead of spending arm and it was we
seemed to end up spending other people's
money I mean I think we've got for
example a decarbonate station of leisure
centers 721
000 pound Grant coming in which
obviously if that hadn't come in we
might have had to take it from our our
own money so um so that is a good
problem to have obviously but that's
that's that we'll get you more detail as
you've requested
thank you for that and I look forward to
hearing the reply into your course
clearly I think it's fantastic that we
are um getting money and other funds
that are available to do these projects
um but you we've obviously putting more
money in there
um you know what are we doing about
planning any future projects
um with you know to spend that money on
we we certainly want to see it being
spent and not not furted away
right I I say I don't have the details
sound whether the cabinet member or an
officer would like to uh you know give
it give a statement now otherwise we can
give details later but if anybody else
wants to uh
yeah we've got counselor Fleming uh
cabinet members so yeah if you come in
please
yes thank you and um thank you um
councilor Mansell I can assure you that
um the money we have there
um it will be put to excellent use
I think our approach as as you as the
members of our committees and task
forces know is very careful and
systematic we don't want or should not
spend money without having a plan for
how it's been spent and without
supporting it with proper evidence
the whole climate change in biodiversity
and agenda is long term
and the plans and proposals that we have
are just starting a lot of them are
based on surveys and assessments some of
which we've done and some of which are
underway and I can assure you that we
have a very ambitious program it's all
set out in the action plans which if you
take take those individual line items
and carry them to their fruition we
could be spending an awful lot of money
and on the environment and I think we
will need to we've got a biodiversity
net gain agenda coming we've got
strategic supplementary planning
documents to work out and and prepare
and put into effect and we've got public
realm and health and well-being all of
which will need input from this fund so
um I'd be glad to take offline any
specifics and follow this up later but
it's not going to sit there and do
nothing I can assure show you
because Fleming thank you for your
assistance councilor Mansell thank you
we're now going to move on to councilor
Passmore please
um thank you very much chairman I'm not
sure whether this is a question for John
or perhaps for the chief executive but I
think it'll be very helpful
um if we could just share some initial
thoughts with all members of how these
work streams for these these big pots of
money might be implemented what sort of
time scales I don't know if there's any
ideas I know it's literally happened on
the spur at the moment but I'm sure um
Arthur will hit has given this some
thought
um beforehand and so as I say whether
it's for you John or Arthur I don't know
but I've been really interested to hear
initial thoughts and how we can all help
and contribute to this work which is you
know really important I'm very pleased
I'd say that straight away
um
to go I I anticipated that because the
Whitehead might pass that in my
direction wasn't more than happy to
um so as you say councilor Passmore none
of this is confirmed yet because uh
frankly you haven't voted on it yet
um but it so it's very early days but in
terms of what I anticipate the kinds of
things that we would need to consider uh
first and foremost it needs to involve
all councilors
um it needs to do so in a balanced way I
also think that it's unlikely to be
successful if we have big round table
discussions like a full council with 34
councilors in it so I anticipate trying
to have some smaller groups uh to pull
together I'd also like to make sure that
it isn't Silo based so I don't want to
see us having a conversation about the
environment separately from housing and
so on and so forth uh not least because
I'm sure you will all want to have an
input in relation to all of those areas
but also more importantly they don't
exist in silos what we do in housing has
an impact on the environment and so on
and so forth so we need to look at it
holistically
um it needs to obviously be driven by
evidence so that you make sure that
you're achieving your best value overall
as an authority so that we're not simply
spending the money because it frankly
would be very easy to spend the money
particularly in the in the Fallout from
covid so to make sure that we're having
the maximum possible impact that we can
possibly do so I anticipate at this
stage that in light of the forthcoming
elections which the government seems to
have confirmed we will be having uh
means and therefore we will be shortly
entering into the pre-election period uh
towards the middle to the end of March
and so as a result what I would propose
uh and what I'm thinking of proposing is
that officers work this up in terms of
exactly how this will work over the next
few weeks or so and then we would start
in Earnest once we come back after those
elections uh in early May and I would
hopefully be hopeful that we can
conclude that work within hopefully by
June uh failing that by July I think
it's essential that we do that because
clearly all councilors will want to see
not just that this money is allocated
but that it's spent and even more
important than that that it has an
impact the only caveat I would add to
that of course is as several have said
already we don't just want to use our
money we want to make sure that we can
draw in other people's money at the same
time as well and work in partnership
with our other colleagues regardless of
whether they're contributing uh
financially whether that's public sector
private sector or voluntary sector so
you can see there's some some thoughts
there but not clearly formulated yet and
I'd obviously be interested in in All
councilors Views as to exactly how you
would like to see that that work as well
and we've got time to build that in very
helpful thank you very much thank you
chairman
thank you
moving on now to counselor matthewson
please
thank you yes I'm grateful to councilor
Passmore who've set off in in the
direction I wish to go which is to to
ask
um councilor Whitehead
what plans the administration have to
actually recruit
some staff
to actually to actually deliver these
projects because it seems to me that the
modest ideas regarding biodiversity so
far
um something that was actually canceled
no canceled deferred
um was was because there wasn't the
management there to actually manage the
project and
um so I think that has been a recurring
theme from our group and particularly
from me over several years now
um we do need the people to actually
deliver the projects and and I think
that the The increased amount of
um money available which is very welcome
um we will need the people we will need
good people to be able to to manage
these projects and and I I do feel that
you know we are stretching our
assistant directors uh and and they they
are you know really not able to to
actually give enough time to the
individual projects that is needed so
what plans for more managers uh we'll go
straight to the chief executive so can I
just say something ahead sorry the
um yeah no I certainly agree with the
council Matheson that our ads have been
remarkably stretched uh during this
situation but this Administration has no
plans to recruit and I say that because
we want outputs and and the Arthur is
head of pay service is the person who
must ensure the Staffing is created I'm
sure he's going to say that anyway but
from our Administration point of view
you know we'll come forward and say in a
cross-party way and say what what our
outcomes are desired and then it will be
up to the officers led by Arthur to to
um to achieve that and I think we'll be
holding his feet to the fire on it but
if I hand over to Arthur Todd what he
wants to say
please do yep absolutely thank you
councilor Whitehead I put my camera on
because I assumed you might want to draw
me in so thank you on that one
um yes I'll probably just go back to
what councilor what had said earlier and
just take the opportunity to thank him
for his words because uh as councilor
Matheson said absolutely our assistant
directors have been stretched but I
would stretch that further if I may all
your officers have been stretched and
they are all heroes for whom I am
incredibly grateful and I'm grateful for
your comments earlier councilweight
ahead and so yes some things haven't
been delivered over the last 10 months
not because we don't want to but because
of the small matter of a pandemic and
that pandemic has absolutely drawn our
offices in multiple directions and I
don't make that by way of excuse but
equally if you were holding my feet to
the fire I would say I think it's a
fairly good excuse in terms of making
sure that all of our residents have
remained safe and well and all the other
priorities that we've had to deliver but
absolutely just to Rebecca against the
whiteheads points I will come forward
with those requests don't don't get me
wrong every time I have seen both the
green and liberal Democrat amendments
and but also the conservative and
independent groups proposals when every
time they say more staff that trust me
I'm never going to reject that offer and
that's always a useful thing to do and
always something that my managers and
and colleagues will always be grateful
for but equally we have a responsibility
as officers not just to accept for that
very kind offer of you from you but to
make sure that we are using that
Resource as wirelessly and as prudently
as possible that sometimes means not to
using our own staff but commissioning
resources from elsewhere so it's getting
that blend right when we when we develop
our approaches and it's making sure that
we have the right resources at the right
times to deploy in the right way and
just to give a point in relation to
councilor mathison's direct question
it's not for me about more managers we
have a management team that isn't just
the assistant directors it includes the
corporate managers as well that makes up
something like seven percent of our
organization so I do think it is lean
but I also think it is mean in that
sense and it is able to deliver but it
possibly does mean more project managers
and I just draw that distinction and of
course there are many more project
managers in the organization not just
the the senior leadership team in that
regard but absolutely I'm more than
welcome to receive as many officers as
you want to throw in my direction whilst
also recognizing the fact that it's a
difficult environment so for example if
I were to go out and recruit an
environmental health officer at the
moment that would be extremely difficult
because they're in high demand across
the whole of the country again because
of the pandemic so some officers are
going to be much harder to come by than
others and I agree with councilor
Mathison it is about ensuring and
maintaining the quality of the resources
that we have at not just having a warm
body but making sure that we have people
that have all the right requisite skills
and values and beliefs and approaches
and so I'm will maintain being picky in
terms of who we recruit rather than just
recruiting to make sure that we have
somebody doing a job sorry that was a
slightly longer
the assistant directors are the people
that we you know particularly
speak to most frequently I didn't I
certainly didn't mean exclusively those
nor indeed would I not actually welcome
a few project managers to to carry
forward some of the
the various schemes that we've got on
the go thank you sorry and just for
complete completeness I think I should
say that this four million pound isn't
isn't is additional to the base budget
and they you know it'll be money that
will be spent I mean if various
additions are made to our compliment
that then go into a base budget in one
year's time two years time or three
years time whatever but this four
million should be seen very much as
additional to the base budget I could
just make that point
okay thank you uh moving on to uh
councilor awesome please
cancel Austin are you there
sorry chairman I'm pressing the wrong
button
um yeah I've got a couple of questions
um the first one is
um on page 37 the statement there that
we can't show what is available for sill
expenditure which I'm quite surprised
about I would have thought that with a
number of current planning applications
in the pipeline the council would have
some indication of what was available
um
appendix a
you're showing a million pounds in
disabled facilities grants
um and I'd just like to know from either
you or the cabinet member with the new
system now available can you explain
what is being done to make sure that
these grants are taken up
um just a small question on elections as
we know the or we assume at the moment
that the County Council on police
command commissioner elections will be
taking place
are you confident that the council has
enough within the budget to cope with
what will be
um considerable more expenditure
in providing those elections safe
and finally
um with at the moment I'm seeing a
hundred and twenty percent rise in
people applying for Universal Credit
what provision is being taken for
um problems that residents may have in
applying are paying their council tax
and with any reduction in council tax
collection
thank you we'll go councilor Whitehead
then the chief executive please okie
dokie um right I mean as you're aware
the the sale that we collect we keep
five percent back for our admin and the
balance is either spent by ourselves or
with Partners the parish councils it's
very difficult to forecast because
um it's paid in installments it's paid
on as properties I understand it become
Ready For Occupational or are occupied
and so we know of my experience and also
from the fact we've got seven and a half
year at land Supply that there is
effectively a tsunami of silma need to
come in but I think um it's a bit like
trying to pin a tail on the on the
donkey it's difficult to put a figure on
that I mean if Catherine Steele is
available I don't want to make
um any further comment on terms of how
we can reliably forecast that or not I
would appreciate her input
foreign please
I don't think there's too much more I
can say in in terms of additions to
councilor Whitehead
um as I say it's very difficult to
project what is going to come in in any
particular year because of the different
stages of applications it's shown in the
table for completeness sake because it's
money that mid-suffolk is sitting on but
it is subject to a very different scheme
in terms of how it is spent and
allocated and as we know from the recent
cabinet meetings proposals often come
forward to propose how that money is
going to be used so there are spending
Rams but we're never sure exactly who is
going to be allocated how much out of
that pot so say it's shown for
completeness really rather than for
necessarily part of this budget setting
in terms of how it gets spent
okay thank you and chief executive
please
um
of questions I'm happy to come in and
deal with the elections one when he's
ready for me too but do the elections
want now then I'll come back to the
other things I've got them written down
thank you then um so in terms of
Elections uh the government has
announced a further chance of money
specifically to help support with the
delivery of the elections uh I believe
it's 31 million pounds from the cabinet
office uh to support directly with the
additional covid costs uh for the
elections
um we don't yet know exactly what those
costs are going to be for us at The
District Council of course runs the
elections but these elections are not
ours so in terms of where those costs
actually fall for these particular
elections
um they will fall upon the County
Council and they will fall on upon the
police and crime commissioner not not
him himself but to the Paro the police
the returning officer for those
elections so we will simply recharge our
costs to those uh but but you're
absolutely right there will be
additional costs not least because we
need to make sure that polling stations
and the count which will take place over
a number of days are covered secure
socially distanced that the polling
stations are cleaned on a regular basis
the queues are maintained with social
distancing in mind so you can
immediately see how there are additional
costs as I say government has earmarked
some money towards that but we shouldn't
have any direct impact upon our finances
although we are likely to have some
Parish elections and neighborhood plan
referendums but again those are funded
and of course the the one advantage and
I think it's the only advantage of
having effectively four counts four
elections at the same time is those
costs are shared across those four
elections so it doesn't all fall on on
one organization as a result
thank you uh back to councilor Whitehead
and I see that you've got the assistant
director of housing here too assist
um yes I mean in terms of the one
million pound in uh disability
facilities facilities grants I mean very
much from a finance point of view we can
accumulate the money but in terms of I
certainly can't say practically how
every penny will be spend but I can be
very grateful for if Gathering could
um put some explanation behind how that
will money will be spent please do thank
you Council Whitehead and uh chair thank
you councilor Orton for your question
um just in Broad summary in relation to
dfg's uh members will be aware
um and I'll just remind members that in
2019-20
um the uh company introduced regulatory
reform order policy which um increased
the thresholds for which
um individuals could claim uh dfgs on a
discretionary basis and then in December
last year
um uh baber and mid Suffolk launched
alongside all Suffolk or for it is their
own Independent Living service which
moves us away from the historic orbit
hia contract obviously members are
conscious and cognizant that um in Years
Gone by we have under spent our budget
I'm pleased to say that on our current
budget monitoring projections for this
year we'll spend more than the budget by
22 000 pounds and that additional
expenditure will come from reserves so
you can see how some of the changes that
we have introduced are having an effect
are meaning that vulnerable individuals
that require dfgs are receiving that
support and help and I'd expect that to
to continue in in years ahead
um I'm just caveat that we'll spend this
year's budget during a pandemic when
obviously uh there's been additional
complications so I think it's a huge
achievement and credit to everyone
involved
I'm really really pleased to hear that
going thank you very much
if I may turn to the final question I
think which was to do the universal
people in Universal Credit and council
tax collection what we're going to do
there as part of my budget preparation I
was looking at some of the councils
particularly councils a council that was
freezing his council tax this year and I
noticed within that those papers it said
that this Council will that Council will
collect a minimum of 24 from all
residents in other words their local
council tax reduction scheme reduces it
down to 76 hours by contrast would you
sit down by to a maximum of 95 so our
most vulnerable residents pay no more
than five percent so already we're going
we are a very generous counsel in that
way the government gave us money to to
help and and that the because our scheme
is already so generous we were actually
struggling first to allocate all that we
sorted out processes and procedures to
do that but the reality is that um
almost memorable are only going to be
paying five percent still and we are
um
having a very
I don't really want to use the word soft
touch but certainly a very um
compassionate approach to collection I
would say
thank you
thank you councilors and uh when I moved
to councilor field please
thank you just like to ask councilor
Whitehead uh something really about his
proposed council tax increase I noticed
the increment in the total council tax
is quite low number changes year by year
but of the order of a couple of hundred
thousand pounds and I know we have
received additional funding I think
8733k we're using 177 of that
so while one would frequently feel that
ensuring our council tax base keeps Pace
with inflation there seems to be a good
idea but this is a pretty exceptional
year in which loads of people are really
challenged by by the covid pandemic and
just wondering if you could run through
again what is your rationale for
um insisting on a council tax increase
rather than than a one-year freeze okay
that's a good question and let me get my
thoughts together on that because
um I think the first point I tried to
make in my in my intuitive speech is
because unusually we are only being
given a one-year settlement so there's
so many uncertainties going forward and
obviously we've got to keep this the
space going forward I think um the other
thing is that the 1.66 percent uh
two-thirds of our homes fall into Bands
A sorry bands b d and c as well as some
and
um I think a Bandy house on top of my
head now it was 18 Pence a month a band
see 21 Pence a month and a band d23
Pence a month
um so the the amounts of money are not
small I mean sorry that's many are small
in terms of anything even two pound 80 a
year you struggle to get a decent coffee
Out outdoors for that these days so it's
not that we're talking about large sums
of money but the reality is that taking
in the hole that council tax increase
brings in 104 000 and then we're going
to ring fence that for covid Recovery uh
business recovery which surely is a
um anybody who's struggling that one
furlough
um will struggle even more if they find
that their employer is no longer there
so looking forward in terms of recovery
we just feel it's the right thing to do
thank you
thank you and moving on to councilor
councilor Wellen please
thank you chair
um I'd like to talk about Gateway 14.
the Star Market area action plan at
paragraph five one one identifies the
site now known as Gateway 14 is having
the potential to be an important
community
resource
I contacted Jay jaynick as part of the
consultation they responded by saying
that the community benefits will be
taken by uh residents could apply for
jobs on the development on the developed
side that didn't seem to be much of a
community benefit to me
so the opposition's budget amendment
recognized the need for a community
liaison group and I'm I know that a
residence group has been formed and the
lead is going to give me some more
information on that I hope it is
extended wider than just the immediate
residence
our budget would include 25k in 2122 and
an indicative sum of 200k in the
following year for Community benefits
as it doesn't seem hard it seemed to be
part of Jane janex uh uh remit what
allocation has been made in the budget
for the provision of community benefits
on the development
thank you um I guess
a job is a benefit benefit if you
haven't got one and um the more we can
create local employment and this is an
enormous site
um very much
I I am a director of Gateway 14 but very
much Gateway 14 it has a certain
autonomy uh in terms of you know its
operations and therefore a lot of its
Bud lots of the budgeting lots of the
spend to bring forward this site you
know is within Gateway 14 rather than
within the Council budget but if Emily
is on the call and wants to add anything
to that that would be happy to take any
addition
we've got Emily
chairman I don't believe she is on the
corner
no she's not okay
um
I think we could probably better ask
that outside of this meeting then I
think in terms of this sort of detail I
think you're looking for uh well can I
just ask a follow-up please please
um and and that is that if it if it
transpires that as you say Council well
I'm sorry I'm I'm being rude I know but
I've got to interrupt um because if you
don't all go into your mod gov we're
going to lose it the connection so all
counselors can you please go into the
mug of uh reactivate it so we don't lose
it and then we'll come back to you
councilwale
by reactivate I assume you just mean
interact with it in some way to yeah
yeah certainly that thank you
that's the plan hopefully it's going to
work if not we'll have to log out log
back in and I'll keep you posted uh
let's go back to council Welling please
thank you chair uh yes if if it is uh
yes
um councilor Whitehead has said that
Gateway 14 is an auto and an autonomous
organization
um and it it's it's set up to develop
the site and make a profit
um it doesn't seem to have any remit in
terms of community benefits will the can
with the council then look at how it
could provide work with Jay Nick and
provide Community benefits on the
development
I think the simple answer to that is yes
but although it's an autonomous vehicle
obviously because it's 100 owned by
shareholders who are the council because
it's got an officer director and a
counselor director and also
um we get a lot of involvement from
other ads such as a business business
um an economy expansion that kind of
thing it's it'd be naive to say it's
just purely set up there to make a
profit it's it's got to certainly wash
its face it's got to do as best as it
can from a finance point of view but
it's obviously a much wider much wider
aspects to it than just a pure Financial
investment
I hope that helps and gives you some
comfort because
yeah I would just like the comfort that
should the should the um liaison group
come up with with relevant and suitable
and and fundable uh Community benefits
they will be carefully looked at
yes absolutely thank you
thank you
um we are now at the end of questions
um but before we go to debate I just
like to say a huge thank you to all the
officers and councilors that are
involved in providing a fairly
comprehensive answers to the questions
answer the questions themselves so we're
now going to move into debate
um
I need to remind you that you can speak
once and you can only speak for three
minutes and this will be timed
Okay who wants to start the debate
[Applause]
anyone excellent okay counselor Passmore
followed by councilor Kasten please
uh thank you chairman I thought we've
got to have some some debate on this net
I just want to say I'm I find it really
really refreshing the way we can now
look forward to I hope in endorsing this
budget but also for those four million
pounds there to work together to do what
really is genuinely best for the whole
district and I think all the years I've
been on here the same length of time as
um Andrew string and one or two others
and of course some of our liberal
colleagues have been there even longer
than I have but this is I think this is
a very very radical approach and I think
we will there is a degree of trust
between all of us and I welcome that
because this is what it should be about
and looking at those categories of
economy housing well-being communities
plus the environment and so on is really
important and the reason I'd like to
just say that chairman is because
when we look at getting the economic
recovery which will benefit everybody
and they're all sorts of guises for
economic recovery so I'm not being hard
edged about that if you see what I mean
it's really about providing a lot of
opportunities those who sadly lost their
job or on short term
um or short incomes and so on but also
for our young people we've spoken a lot
about that tonight they are our future
and we have got to do everything
possible to do that and to attract that
inward investment we have to make the
district as attractive as possible
because it is a competitive business and
so if we look at things like well-being
be it Leisure the environment the visual
environment all these things are really
going to make a tremendous difference
and I really hope it will put
mid-suffolk on the map and I think this
budget is actually capable of doing it
it's the start of a long process of
course there's extra four million pounds
this will be the start of a journey and
the last thing I'd like to say when we
do look at the um where we do this
looking at procurement we can help we
can look at social value and that I've
always been very keen on that and as a
really tiny point on this but I think
really significant
um with my um agricultural hat on here
when we're looking at planting schemes
which they'll be I really do think it's
important that we focus on procuring
supplies locally but also native species
not those that come from overseas and so
on because that will really have an
impact so I really really welcome that
I'm delighted to
um hear that the the green and liberal
Democrat group are going to join with us
and I think that
branch of dare us well no I do mean it
actually friendship and cooperation will
be extended to everybody so um well done
for everybody who's been involved in
that so I shall certainly be supporting
this budget with the amendment thank you
thank you uh councilor William could you
turn your
um camera off and I will come back to
you on your question on your debate
Point uh so we moved to councilor
casting please
thank you very much I'd like to um thank
um the councilor Passmore for putting on
his agricultural hat as a sort of
warm-up for me and speaking as a farmer
but um yeah it's good how the um the
opposition the green lib Dems are um I
um we're drawing that amendment I think
that's a that's really good that we're
going to work together and put politics
aside but and Mr chairman
this um this budget I hope that we can
agree on tonight is a budget that
delivers on many things
we're in a financial position of
strength and it's time to zero in on the
recovery from a worldwide pandemic
when I am joined the council five years
ago we looked far less more on certain
budgets than this and I was told by
someone we've got to stand for value for
money and spending must be
evidence-based and also councilor
Whitehead has taught me which had become
a bit of a catchphrase of his under
promise and over deliver but also he's
taught me a great principle of
accounting recognize expenses and
liabilities as soon as possible but
recognize assets and revenues when you
know you're definitely going to receive
them and in this case that's brought us
a good healthy Surplus and we can do a
lot of good things with that
especially
um under the excellent staff and
resource management of the chief
executive backed up by the Endeavors of
his hard-working officers and stuff but
Mr chairman we have big Ambitions to
build the type of society our residents
deserve the leader has said and that
we're not starting from scratch and
we've got a lot of plans that are
already in place and being delivered
so Mr chairman we're delivering on
homelessness housing 75 people that were
previously homeless on the environment
we are now acting on the first wave of
our crucial climate change measures in
may we would change our diesel refuse
lorries to hvo removing 880 tons of
carbon from the streets and Roads that
we live on 90 less CO2 from the
essential waste collection activity
housing we we're building 70 homes and
need a market on two sites 50 of which
will be affordable we are committing to
acquiring 97 new properties and Stow
Market wool Pitt and Hawley
and we've commissioned several programs
and these include active schools healthy
eating dementia social isolation
programs older people living well
and we are now tackling digital
isolation
we're supporting our young people we now
are funding Innovation and skills
initiatives this includes a fantastic
project the mix for young people in
education not in Education and Training
we're also supporting Innovation labs
and we continue to support them in their
growth and development so I fully
support this budget it delivers on
changes and Carries those principles of
value for money in evidence-based
spending please join me thank you Mr
chairman I could see I'd run out of time
there
you're very very close uh for those
extra 10 seconds I thought we'd let you
continue okay thank you and moving on
now to councilor Fleming please
thank you
um chairman and
um good evening everybody I'm going to
try to speak quickly which is um I find
a bit difficult
um because I do want to mention a few
things that are going on within my
portfolio but I am delighted to support
this budget which I believe to be both
responsible and forward-looking I also
wish to recognize and welcome the good
ideas in the opposition budget if it if
ours passes and then I look forward to
working with all members on those
aspects that affect my portfolio
prudent use of public money as well as
very proactive pursuit of Grants and
match funds has given us the ability to
finance a range of projects which are in
The Wider interests of our residents
I'm particularly prized pleased that we
have been able to collect to allocate
500 000 pounds to the environment over
the past year unable to do so again this
year
notwithstanding the pressures of the
pandemic
we've come a long way in two years and
are making some important and
fundamental shifts in the way resources
are allocated our commitments to climate
change and biodiversity are documented
in the action plans which I think most
members are familiar
our priorities for our carbon budget
have been identified from surveys and
assessments conducted over the past year
and emissions from our waste Fleet and
from Leisure centers are the highest
priorities to reduce our carbon
footprint
as counselor Caston has mentioned we're
on the process of procuring
hydro-cheated vegetable oil supplies to
replace Diesel and not only does this
reduce our carbon footprint it also
reduces the range of other pollutants
that are present in diesel
we intend to also invest in a 550 000
liter above ground storage tank and will
need to put some money into the
anticipated additional costs of the hvo
itself
improvements to Leisure centers our
second largest emitter include
installing solar car ports upgrading the
roof to take solar panels installing
ground Source heat and switching to a
green energy tariff the letter process
should be complete by the end of March
this year
the accounts will then be managed with
byvertis along with the rest of the
council's energy portfolio these plans
at the Forefront of the available
Technologies and Storm Arctic will be
the pilot something I'm very pleased
about
the investment needed for these projects
I'm proud to say is greatly augmented by
match funded grants
I just go on to mention EV Electro um
electric vehicle charging
we have um joined the energy saving
trust local government support program
which in which offers a range of free
services and gives us access to the
Department of Transport support
which also gives us access to funding of
75 of the cost of the charging schemes
we are working with UK power networks to
find the best locations and site
selection for new charge points so that
they go in places that can be supported
by the grid
for biodiversity and councilor Fleming
if you could sum up you are over time I
will sum up now by saying that I could
go on but this gives a flavor of how
this budget item will be used and as I
said earlier our program is ambitious
and represents the fundamental long-term
shift thank you can I just say my last
sentence please
very quickly yeah okay investment in the
natural environment and in energy
a fish spills over into many other
Council responsibilities and will
benefit people's lives in a multitude of
ways thank you
Council flattman please
thank you chair
as you know communities there's the
heart of everything we do so I'm just
going to run you through some of the
things that we have in our mind
in early 2019 I presented our community
strategy to full Council this strategy
described our vision for communities
that thrive now and in the future are
aimed to provide guidance support and
inspiration to our communities and our
objectives are for all our communities
to be attractive successful and connect
to places for what people to work and
live
the action plan to deliver this strategy
was nearing completion just as the
pandemic struck in March 2020 since then
we have seen the very best of our
communities as town and Parish councils
good neighborhood schemes and residents
associations were joined by new
community sub support groups and pop-up
food banks to ensure that our vulnerable
residents were supported we know what
our communities are capable of
delivering our community strategy Act
action plan has been developed with
recovery firmly in mind and I am
confident that with this additional
money we will be able to accelerate the
plans we had and deliver new projects
and ideas that will invigorate our
communities and support them to flourish
as we look ahead to more positive times
I do not want to be
prescriptive about oh I can't move my
mouse
can I have some more time chair
I do not want to be
prescriptive about exactly what we will
invest in because we need to listen and
learn from our communities and partners
but I do have some examples of the kinds
of things we will help look to invest in
helping communities to improve their
Community facilities Village Halls
Sports pictures playgrounds Open Spaces
footpath networks providing more support
to help neighborhood planning groups
realize their ambitions extra capacity
for Community safety so that we aren't
just dealing with anti-social Behavior
but we're getting upstream or of it to
minimize it happening in the first place
and supporting communities to
mitigate and adopt to climate change and
provide the biodiversity net gain
through their own local efforts
and for well-being I'm equally excited
the well-being strategy has been
developed during the pandemic and will
come to this Council for adoption in the
coming months again I do not want to be
over prescriptive at this stage but
there are so many opportunities here
including developing social prescribing
for young people addressing social
isolation isolation
loneliness through working with people
like the rural coffee Caravan building
on holiday activities through supporting
cooking and physical activities I think
we've got it thank you
thank you very much 35 seconds thank you
thank you and I hope someone will finish
this off for me in a minute thanks a lot
okay moving on to councilor Byrne please
sorry I didn't realize it was next uh
bigger problem
um okay it's um Cabinet member for
planning
uh I recognize that planning itself is
is one of those areas that enables
outcomes across the entire range of
corporate priorities from housing and
economic growth to communities
well-being and and environment
um uh so so indeed I I do uh recognize
what uh councilor Morley and our chief
exec were saying about we could we
shouldn't be working in in in silos
um
I've always encouraged officers to ask
if they need additional resource but the
creation of these specific budgets for
each of our priorities
does create some exciting opportunities
I know some of my colleagues have
described we do not want to need uh we
do not want or need to be too
prescriptive immediately but some of the
examples are the ways that I will seek
to improve outcomes include
um a new fixed term resource to provide
more support for neighborhood planning
our neighborhood plans officer does a
fantastic job in helping communities
develop their plans but as we get more
adopted plans I would also like us to do
more to help communities to realize the
Ambitions that their plans articulate
I would like us to have a resource that
will help bridge the professional and
Technical elements of plan making with
the softer people and Community aspects
of those plans
I would also propose additional officer
resource to support communities to
update their conservation areas and make
sure that local Heritage interests can
be properly evidenced and reviewed
it is also clear to me that good design
is becoming increasingly recognized as a
vital part of the planning system we
don't currently have any specialist
design resource in our planning team and
I suggest that we invest in an in-house
specialist design officer
finally as with good design it is also
clear that both through our own action
and that of our government
biodiversity has an increasingly
important place in the planning system
and officers have my encouragement
designed a bio biodiversity
opportunities role and in-house
ecologist if you will this would enable
us to reduce our Reliance on Place
services and build capacity and
knowledge across our internal teams
so whilst I can't
um muster the excitement and enthusiasm
as in that my colleague councilor
flattman manages
these examples do demonstrate my
commitments to achieving our corporate
Vision to build great opportune great
communities with bright and healthy
Futures that everyone is proud to call
home
and I therefore will be supporting this
budget because that's what it will
enable me to do
thank you Council Byrne uh councilor
Stringer please
sorry chair Council rieburn was the head
of me uh not on my list it's you so uh
thank you thank you chair thank you
chair uh thank you for the opportunity
to speak
um just wanted to say it's also it's all
very sudden uh this sort of Change of
Atmosphere uh and just I'd like to
remind councilors in the administration
uh we could have shared toys at any time
since this council's Inception
uh and if we want to share lots of toys
now that could have been happening all
the way through since the very start uh
what to make the point about the 104 000
of the council tax increase uh just want
to make the point that is actually a
fraction of any under spend we've we've
had today uh and certainly a fraction of
any under spend this council's had in
the last decade
uh
also wanted to sort of make the point uh
that
we've got little evidence that 2122 will
be any difference in terms of under
spins uh so you know this constant
understanding is becoming you know
slightly embarrassing frankly
um uh as a service to the electorate
though I think we need to make sure that
all of what we do has Integrity I have
at times I have once as a leader of the
opposition group voted for an
administration's budget
uh I don't think I'll be doing it today
despite this outbreak of four million
pounds in peace and love uh one of the
reasons why is is to actually uphold a
conservative election pledge uh in the
election that goes here uh the
conservative team did promise that they
would keep council tax increases to an
absolute minimum while ensure every
penny is well spent providing Frontline
Services uh
we'll ignore the last bit of that uh I I
personally don't believe that the cancer
tax increases this time have been kept
to an absolute minimum uh not that I
normally vote along conservative party
lines uh but I don't feel I can support
this uh while it's not showing that
integrity that's not being me being poor
in terms of not wanting to work together
that's just be you know I don't judge
you on what you say well I actually
judge you on what you do so I'm gladly
work with you if this budget does
succeed but actually with this change in
it coming so close actually I would have
preferred a bit more time to look at the
consequences it's because we could have
ironed this hundred and odd thousand out
and then I would have been supporting
your budget wholeheartedly thank you
chair
can't hear you chair I know John yeah
I'm now there so uh we're now going to
go to councilor Brewster uh and the
reason his hand isn't he's not got the
ability to do that but he has texted so
councilor Brewster
thank you
um yeah the economy continues to suffer
as the covered Batman pandemic has led
to further lockdowns in line with the UK
in mid-suffolk we've experienced high
growth of Universal Credit claimants and
rising in work poverty together with a
fall in apprenticeships and high numbers
of Staff furloughed with particular
hardship for those businesses in the
retail hospitality and Leisure sectors
however alongside intervention for
recovery
we must continue to support the growth
of businesses in our district through
stimulating Innovation encouraging
entrepreneurship and creating the right
conditions for Enterprise
The Innovation Awards we held in
November 2020 were one of the first
steps to foster a new future of
innovation with over 100 businesses
involved in the event and a diverse
range of nominees and winners from all
sectors
from the success of the awards we're now
creating an innovation network with
regular e-letters a range of topical
speakers and collaborate collaboration
opportunities
the one million pound funding for
economy will be a further opportunity to
accelerate this growth and innovation in
our district
I would like just to outline some of the
areas where we are already working and
where perhaps depending on the cross
party
workshops further investment might be
able to be made
deliver development of economies for
healthier lives program joint initiative
between economy and communities team to
provide skills development for young
people
transferable skills for people in work
and a knowledge transfer light program
for fast-track growth of smes
creation of more Innovation herbs pop-up
programs
pop-up program to enable new businesses
ideas to be tested in local high streets
and they could also include youth
Enterprise stores
development of new hotdisk workspace at
Cross Street in eye the business case
will come before cabinet in just the
next two weeks
further support for Freeport that's if
the bid moves onto the next stage
development of a program of inspiration
aspiration for young people to include
Innovation workshops in schools creation
of a youth Enterprise Awards awards
development of feasibility and design
work for business-led skills and
Innovation Center at Gateway 14.
support for high-speed Broadband rollout
further funding for Town Center Vision
investment boards to include development
of cultural strategy for Market towns
and cultural group in Star Market
spend on the above examples would help
us to achieve the outcomes of our
emerging economic strategy for our
district to be more connected and
sustainable more Innovative and creative
and to develop schools and skills and
success while supporting our businesses
to be resilient and encourage higher
levels of growth as we start to recover
from the impacts of covert 14 19. Mr
chairman I look forward to working with
the cross party group and we'll be
supporting this budget
thank you councilor councilor scarf
please
thank you Mr chairman yes well firstly
I'd like to welcome
um the leaders comments uh earlier on
which is seems like an awful long time
ago
um but she said I believe that she
wanted to protect the most disadvantaged
uh of our residents in our district and
had a clear understanding of our
residents needs
um I'd like to sort of speak just to put
some context on that
um
as Vice chair of the mid-suffic overview
and scrutiny committee
um at this week's joint meeting baber
and mid-suffolk we heard at firsthand
from the chief executive officers of the
citizens advice that represent uh those
two authorities
um about how they've transformed the way
that they operate during the pandemic uh
new technology more telephones more
Computing devices Etc
um and how they're reaching out to our
residents in the north of the district
um up near I Etc
we also heard more importantly I think
this is really the Salient point that
mid-suffic citizens advice actually has
a budget shortfall of thirty thousand
pounds currently
um and as a stone Market relief charity
trustee I can also confirm that
um the midsomic ca did say this week
that The Stone Market relief trust
unfortunately due to their own funding
issues and pressures on their their
resources have had to produce their
three-year fifteen thousand pounds a
year Grant to just five thousand pounds
a year for the following three years
that's another reduction of ten thousand
pounds per year
um I would point out that all statutory
bodies including this Council rely very
heavily on citizens advice
um and they are often the first Port of
Call
um we also heard in their own words from
the citizens advice executive officers
that they expect a tsunami uh that will
will follow once renteria's evictions
and the end of the furlough schemes
begins and obviously this will
inevitably increase their workload so
I'm sure that every counselor recognizes
the contribution made by citizens advice
on behalf of our residents
um and I would just appeal that when we
go through the process of this
collaborative working that we don't
forget that because I think they're very
Salient points thank you chair thank you
councilor uh we'll move to councilor
haddington please
thank you chair
um the uh
the uh 100 1000 1 million
um pounds allocated for housing will be
most welcomed members are aware that in
February um 2019 my predecessor
presented to full Council our current
homes and housing strategy and our
homelessness reduction and rough
sleeping strategy for approval at the
time these strategies were approved
unanimously by all members and we now
find ourselves entering the third year
of these five-year strategies our vision
is for residents to live an affordable
and high quality homes that enable them
to build settled safe and healthy lives
within sustainable and thriving
communities our vision is for residents
to live in affordable and high quality
homes that enable them to build set
so I'm repeating myself
um the homes and housing strategy was
developed with nine strategic aims and
both these strategies were supported
with Comprehensive action plans for
which our overview and scrutiny
committee assess each year the level of
progress made against the original plans
I'm confident that any additional
reserves would support investment in
accelerating our existing plans we've
already had huge successes but this
opportunity to invest further could
support a range of activities subject to
any necessary approvals and I'm looking
forward to working with this cross party
and I'm going to support this budget
thanks very much
thank you councilor and moving to
councilor Richardson please
uh thank you chair um as ever I think
our thanks should go to uh councilor
Whitehead uh to the assistant director
for corporate resources and to The Wider
Finance team for their hard work in
producing this budget
um I'd also like to thank councilors
field and all boys both um for the work
they've put in
um to their Amendment but also for the
gracious way in which they've conducted
themselves this evening
um I absolutely uh share Capital
Whitehead's commitment to trust party
working and I look forward to helping to
deliver that in practice
um turning to the matter at hand I think
this budget is a real step forward for
our district we are recommending a
modest rise in council tax to continue
our hard-won financial sustainability
whilst making significant Investments
across Moon Suffolk in our key priority
areas and I think that's exactly the
point that needs to be emphasized
because it's only because of the former
that we are able to do the latter and
what we have in this budget is something
that could be a real game changer for
our district and we have in front of us
the opportunity to build on the
ambitious program of work we've already
undertaken and go even further
uh in particular I want to welcome the
proposal for a one million pound
investment in well-being and this has
long been a priority for mid-suffic and
a personal passion of mine and I think
it's now more important than ever
Council Whitehead was absolutely right
and the most important aspect of all of
this is our outputs
um now I don't want to preempt the
well-being strategy which will be
published in the coming months but there
are so many opportunities here and
councilor flatman has mentioned uh
several of them but we can also extend
and adapt our active well-being and
active schools programs and support our
support clubs and Village Halls to
recover and build themselves back
um following what would have been a
difficult year for many the reason that
this is so important is because it will
have a profound and long-lasting impact
on our communities we will not just be
reaching with the easy wins for the low
hanging fruit and we must and we will
use this money to reap the rewards in
the long run but this isn't just about
the investment in well-being that will
deliver the health healthier communities
that we want to see through our work in
other areas such as the environment we
can begin to see why the benefits to
Public Health and well-being from
reductions in pollution to increased
access to Green spaces as councilor
Fleming mentioned earlier
um I think that's that's really
significant and what we can do to
benefit all of our communities not just
the things that we we have a legal and
statutory responsibility for but the
wider public good that we can do as a
district council
um ultimately I think of course I
recognize that the next few months will
not be easy but I fundamentally believe
that this is a really ambitious budget
that will ensure that mid-suffolk rises
to the challenge that we know we face
and for that reason it has my whole
heart in support and I would encourage
all councilors to vote in favor of it
thank you chair thank you councilor and
moving on to councilor Gould please
thank you very much chairman I was just
conscious that there are many counselors
for whom this will only be their second
budget and who may be forgiven for
thinking that mid-suffic strong
financial position is the norm among
councils it isn't
I worked out that I've been involved in
31 Council budget settings 29 of the 31
have had to resolve deficits typically
through savings cuts and efficiencies
the two the other two are of course
mid-suffolk last year and now this year
the number of factors that have led to
the strength of the council's finances
and not least the skill and hard work of
the finance team
strong financial planning characterized
by prudence and Enterprise over a number
of years have provided us with a solid
foundation
as Council Whitehead said sifco makes a
substantial annual contribution to the
council equivalent in the coming year to
the council tax revenue from 8 800 bandi
properties
an area that impresses greatly is the
council's success in attracting external
grant funding for key projects in
mid-suffolk we've drawn in just short of
two million pounds in the last 12 months
a remarkable achievement that has
enabled projects from solar car ports
through
tackling homelessness to the
decarbonization of of leisure centers
you've heard from the leader and cabinet
colleagues about how we're using the
fruits of Good Financial Management to
the wide benefit of our district and as
an Administration we have a strong sense
of collective pride in being able to
develop and take forward a program of
projects and invest Investments That
across key areas such as environment
well-being business Housing and
Community knowing these that will
progress our strategic goals
and committing these substantial
resources we can't lose sight of the
need to ensure a financially sustainable
future and the things we can do to help
recommendation 3.3 of the report would
allow the council wall uh flexible use
of capital receipts obtained within the
qualifying period to fund service
transformation and thereby release
savings this is an obvious and valuable
opportunity to take and I hope the
recommendation will be supported
uh but there are the known unknowns as
someone once said and and these include
uncertainties are behind the one-year
settlement and the deferral of fair
funding the business rate reviews and
the replacement for the new homes bonus
as these issues become resolved our
projected future surpluses can be given
higher levels of certainty which may
lead us to reconsider future levels of
council tax account if you could
summarize it you're at three minutes
okay thanks so I'm delighted to vote for
this excellent budget and the benefits
for our district that will result thank
you very much Mr chairman thank you and
councilor eberne please
thank you very much chair
um this has been a very difficult year
for many people
and the staff at the council are amongst
those who have done an incredible job in
Rising to the challenge that the covid
pandemic has presented
many projects have halted While others
such as increased support for voluntary
groups have had to be ramped up
but during this year we still needed to
deliver for our communities so achieving
a surplus and therefore not spending 2
million out of approximately 10 million
budget seems excessive
and then we are faced with a draft
budget for 2122 where the government is
giving us an extra 733 000 pounds and we
still can't spend it
within the draft budget is a
recommendation to put up council tax in
the year when everyone while the hedge
fund managers is struggling and we need
to give our residents a break
additionally we don't need the extra
funds this year we already have the
money in the bank and I can't vote for
an increase in council tax
the budget paper talks about thriving
communities but we can't support this
unless we spend some money I am pleased
however that our presence on the council
has ensured more consideration being
given to climate change and
environmentalist issues even if the one
million 500 000 and then one million
hasn't been completely spent
our amendment was very modest in its
proposed spend in relation to the 4
million that is being stashed away on
projects as yet to be decided while in
addition having a nine million pound
Surplus over the next three years the
portfolio holder John Whitehead
mentioned Rosie I mean it's positively
fluorescent
we don't need to be talking about making
savings year on year what we do need to
do is spend some of these funds in our
communities and help them to thrive
once again overall reserves have
increased to an amount almost double our
net budget
we need to stop hoarding this and again
this doesn't even include the proposed 4
million on various priorities
we did not withdraw our Amendment
lightly and I welcome the opportunity to
discuss these priorities with my fellow
colleagues across the council we do too
little of this as it is I hope the
portfolio holder speeches don't limit
these discussions and they will actively
continue cross-party working through the
term of this Council not just in the
next few months
however I really urge everyone to think
about how these funds can be put to best
use for the benefit of all our
communities and that we use these funds
now thank you chair
thank you counselor
um we're now going to councilor
mathiason please
you're on mute counselor
yeah it's still a it might be your
microphone I think it's quite High
perhaps
should I come back to you no oh I've got
you you're back okay thank you chair the
um there was mentioned earlier the fact
that that we should create an attractive
environment to to attract quality jobs
and I quite agree with that and indeed
quality people and
um because there is you know quite a
migration from town to to Countryside as
we know at the moment but I wanted to
see that apply to Gateway 14. that is
our big job creation project and
it it is it is not at the moment heading
towards the attractive environment that
was promised in the
um snow market area action plan and the
the design brief for that project which
I supported at the time and we've got
we've got to do much more in
councilor wellem has said in terms of
benefiting the community but also
creating an attractive environment
working environment on that land
um the public will really not understand
if we
on our own land on our own projects we
don't do something which is better than
the developers would do to who are
basically just interested in making
money and the the same thing
unfortunately does go for our housing
projects where where we're not we're not
building the Exemplar uh ultra low
energy
houses that we ought to be building that
we've asked and asked and asked to be
built
and I think the other point I want to
make is the um
we 18 months or more ago now we declared
a climate and a biodiversity emergency
the word is emergency and we just
haven't moved fast enough to actually
tackle those two we said we recognized
in emergency but we haven't actually
worked a speed which is justifiable to
use that word emergency and and I for
the the trivial amount of money as it is
in the budget
um
the the council tax increase will bring
I really cannot see any any point in
doing that and I I can't support that
um whatever that
um recommendation number is
thank you
thank you councilor uh councilor Mansell
please
uh thank you chair
um now we've heard a lot about
um uh lots of good intentions uh from
some of the portfolio holders who've
spoken already on this debate uh and a
lot of those good intentions I can't
possibly disagree with uh and I really
do hope that this budget enables actions
and not just words
uh and I I really do I I welcome the
prospect of of cross party working uh
with the administration in order to make
sure that we do get the best outcomes
for our communities I I disagree with uh
councilor Passmore when he says that
this is a radical approach we are after
all half of the council and as cancer
string has already said we could have
been working together 18 months ago
um so yes I I really do welcome it and I
think this is a fantastic step forward
um in an approach to work together
um however
um similarly to councilors e burn
Matheson and Stringer I I can't really
support the administration's proposal to
increase the council tax I I won't
repeat what they've said
um you know we do have a lot in our
reserves and 104
um is a small amount compared with the
amount of money that we have stashed
away
um so uh you know I really can't support
that that part of the um of the budget I
think that's number 3.2 for a jump for
councilor mathison's uh comments uh but
but I do welcome I do welcome the
ability to or the options are working
together and I think I think that's a
great step forward so thank you very
much uh for that
thank you counselor
um we're going to move to counselor War
boys please
thank you thank you chair
uh
yes I
I I I too I'm looking forward to uh
working in this cross party
uh workshops and hope I've got the
opportunity to contribute to investing
in our communities
um I thank councilor Richardson's for
his
his comments
but I fear I'm going to sound a little
ungracious uh this time
on page 46 we look at um the forecast
for the budget surplus and year on year
it increases from an estimated three
so three million 632
000 at the end of 22 23 to
well over 8 million pounds by the end of
24 25.
and this causes me
concern
we've just heard
uh a huge diversity
of ideas coming forward and I'm looking
forward to working with fellow
counselors from across the chamber in
order to deliver some of these ideas I
think they do
satisfy some of the needs of our
community
but I'm concerned that some of these
ideas now coming forward have been
stifled
in previous years in order to develop
in order to sustain a budget surplus
I think
in the light of these
this
the comments that have
congratulated the Council on being in a
comfortable position
uh we are going out to our communities
and asking them to support an increase
in the council tax which is small
I agree which does provide only a
hundred and four thousand
extra
money but I think the principle of
asking for more
in these difficult times
I find out I can't support that aspect
of this budget
thank you thank you councilor moving to
councilor EK pen young please
thank you Mr chairman
um my colleague and Cabinet member for
economy talked about technology in his
uh little speech and there's no doubt in
my mind that we're going to need a lot
of innovation and creativity to work our
way out of the very difficult economic
situation that the pandemic has put us
in
so I'm pleased to hear that these will
be key areas of focus and note that we
will be participating in the inaugural
and virtual AI Festival next week being
hosted out of BG's Research Center in
industrial park which will be attended
by a large number of companies from our
district
I don't know if it's widely known but
Suffolk is one of the world's most
prolific locations for patented AI
Innovations so we're looking to hear and
see some great things from that Festival
next week
we're also going to be extending the
virtual High Street concept successfully
trialled in Sudbury to our other key
Market towns including hardly and Star
Market where in fact this unique
platform was developed at The Innovation
Hub there
participation in the virtual High Street
program will be free to use this in the
first year of operations
I'm also very pleased that we will be
developing Innovation workshops in
schools and colleges and planner youth
Enterprise award scheme to get our young
people involved in playing their part in
the Regeneration and the growth of our
economy with their ideas energy and
enthusiasm
and this is I think a very key element
of what we'll be doing going forward
so I believe that with this budget which
I will be supporting and which shows the
kind of financial sustainability that we
all desire we have a great opportunity
to really push on from where we are
today to get our economy back on an evil
cure and grow from there and I look
forward to being able to play my part in
in the whole process thank you
thank you counselor moving on to
councilor Mellon please
um thank you Mr chairman
um
I think that this budget is a missed
opportunity there was an opportunity
here to send a message of support to our
residents by budgeting for a freeze in
council tax this year
residents and households are struggling
with the pandemic with uncertainty and
with financial stress and I think people
will also struggle to understand why a
council's so flush with funds needs to
increase tax on them
whilst I welcome the offer of cross
party working
this has come very late in the day and I
find myself unable to support a budget
that increases tax when there is no need
to do so
thank you
thank you councilor moving on now to
councilor Pratt please
can I support you there
thank you hello there sorry yes um I
just wanted to um to say that I
unfortunately won't be supporting this
budget and just keeping it brief for a
couple of reasons
that to be honest I haven't already been
outlined um the raising of council tax
at a time when you know we a lot of
people a lot of our residents are
struggling
to make ends meet
um when we're already kind of you know
the books are well balanced and we we
have surpluses seems to be unjust and
unreasonable
um you know to push another Point
further
um I feel I feel that it's um we've you
know we we could be using the money that
we've got to do more
and to give you an example
um we we currently are
um laying out
um some improvements
um to make homes more energy efficient
and uh to make sure they're better
insulated we could be using more of our
funds to to ensure that this is you know
going further we could do more in that
um also uh
you know we've we've already gone over
the idea that we don't need more offices
but as councilor Matson pointed out
earlier
um officers being overstretched across
the board hasn't really been a new issue
um this is something that the greens and
perhaps the lib Dems have been bringing
up for quite a long time now that we do
need more more offices
um on the ground to carry out projects
um so unfortunately
um whilst I do applaud the willingness
to work across party
um I'm not going to be able to support
this this budget thank you
thank you councilor and moving on to
councilor geek please
thank you chair
cast and defined
frustrations budget which was developed
entirely by the blue half of the council
as putting politics aside our
conservative priorities not politics and
then councilor Stringer is working hard
to fulfill a conservative Manifesto
promise in the teeth of opposition from
the administration this is indeed a
strange evening
my view is that I'm not prepared to vote
for this budget in this year of all
years when we have such huge reserves
and on top of those enormous underspends
every year this year of all years we
should spend we should we should invest
as many have said in councilor Even's
words we should stop Hoarding in common
with counselor Stringer I'm also going
to defend conservative promises or at
least try to and I hope that some from
the conservative side will follow me I
will defend conservative promises where
they chime with green values I'll argue
for greater investment which is after
also desperately needed in this world of
austerity and cuts and and
um and massive under investment but I'll
also argue against raising council tax
while we're failing to use this money to
provide investment and services
thank you councilor uh moving on to
councilor mayor please
thanks Jeff
um I've been sitting listening
um with interest to everything that's
gone before and I I am staggered really
um I think it's a fantastic budget
other councils are struggling to make
ends meet making cuts and yet
mid-suffolk are building a springboard
that's going to take our district
forward
um
that springboard is based on reserves
and reserves are built up by underspends
soon after joining the council
um I was interested to read an article
in the newspaper where one of our number
spoke about the reserves being
unnecessary
well I think those reserves are
essential they're very necessary and
those reserves have allowed this budget
that will take mid-suffolk forward
it's not going to be easy and I don't
think we should at any of us should
underestimate the amount of work that's
going to be required and I think the
um Council of Fleming's comments about
the climate task force are well made
it's very easy to spend money it's very
difficult to spend money to ensure that
you get the biggest bang for your buck
and that's what we're looking for
but I'm also conscious that we stand on
the shoulders of others
these reserves that we've used this year
or intend to use or propose to use this
year were built by others and we must
now build reserves for those that come
after us
and so I'm delighted to hear that
Gateway 14 is going so well I I've
always been a fan of sifco and sifco
continues to deliver to build reserves
so that we can have a foundation in the
future that others can deal with issues
and let's not forget that reserves allow
us
to handle unexpected events without
cutting services
that is what we're doing today we are
building a budget for the future for
mid-suffolk and I'm very proud to
support it and indeed I really struggle
to understand why anybody who puts the
welfare of the residents of mid-suffolk
would not support a budget that delivers
millions of pounds of investment this is
an excellent budget and I support thank
you
thank you councilor and uh finally
because we're approaching Guillotine uh
we'll go to counselor Hicks
uh thank you very much Mr chairman
um every year I normally start off by
always saying the same thing that I
think it's really important that we
reflect on the budget and across all
councils across the country it is a time
for us as counselors to think about what
we're here to do uh we're in this
virtual chamber because the
responsibility we have and it's a big
responsibility and our responsibility
today is to look after the residents of
mid-suffolk and we need to decide how
we're going to spend that sum of money
and what we do best and the direction of
travel for the future of this uh
District
conservative Council in mid-suffic we
have a really strong record of
delivering for our residents and it's a
long history it goes back many many
years and it's one that we should all be
rightly proud
um of course no conservative Council
this year has had to have an emergency
budget and that's because we are prudent
and we do not put up council tax lightly
it is quite interesting for me today
because of course last week I was
criticized by the liberal Democrats and
the greens for not putting up council
tax to the maximum amount which is what
the liberal Democrat and greens wanted
to do to take the maximum amount in
another chamber and today there's
criticism by the same party for putting
it up at all and last week I was told
the burden on the electorate was
acceptable by the liberal Democrat in
Greens and today I'm told by the same
parties opposite that it's the opposite
now of course we do know that we do have
support in place for the most vulnerable
who can utilize reduction support
services around council tax
but we as conservatives do not flip-flop
we are consistent we take a consistent
approach and that is one of prudence
it's one of sound financial management
we are consistent
as we're all well aware the budget being
set is being set in a very challenging
and certainly uncertain times due to the
ongoing impacts of covid-19 but despite
this we can absolutely with this budget
look forward with confidence
the investment in our district is
important and I think it's really
excellent work by officers and councilor
Whitehead and the leader of the council
in coming forward with a budget that's
going to put additional investment into
the economy into housing into
communities into well-being and focusing
on covid related business recovery so
I'm really delighted the approach being
taken by the leader of our Authority the
leader believes in working in
partnership with others and I've seen
that myself when she goes out at spsl
local outright engagement board through
the Suffolk waste partnership and more
and it's by working together we can
achieve so much more and I really hope
that the opposition mean that they want
to work with us and actually really show
that going forward rather than just
talking about it so it sounds good and I
really support this budget and I really
look forward to seeing the work together
going forward with the opposition thank
you Mr chairman kosa thank you I noticed
there are two more councilors wanting to
debate but we are approaching Guillotine
and I'm really conscious of that
therefore I'm going to have to basically
go to the vote on this motion end the
debate so we can get guillotine in in
time
so my apologies that you didn't get your
debate
however if there is a consensus of
opinion we can continue that debate
if I hear nothing to the contrary that's
the way we'll go
good nothing to contrary sorry to Chad
council do you want us to put our hands
up to a sponsor no if you if you oppose
what I'm saying just say so and if you
don't please I think it's it's an
extremely important important item on
the agenda and I think it's only fair
that those people that want to speak
should be able to speak more than happy
so as there are no opposite there is no
opposition to what I've just suggested
that's the way we're going to do we're
going to continue so going on to Council
of field please
thank you chair and thank you for that
decision I'll keep it incredibly short
uh I heard what councilor Hicks said I I
want to point out is quite correct we've
supported opposite directions in in two
councils one Council had a predicted
budget Gap deficit of 148 million pounds
over the park next three years the other
Council has a surplus
depending how you measure it of
somewhere up in the 18 million brackets
uh I think it's quite logical that one
Council has a real need for additional
Finance
and however painful you have to take
that
and the other Council does not have a
clear need for that finance and
therefore we feel we this Council should
not raise tax and I don't I'll leave it
at that point that's all
thank you counselor and uh councilor
opton please
uh well actually determine uh that's
absolutely fine exactly what I intended
to say that John field has just said
exactly that it's a complete different
situation
um and certainly as far as the County
Council is concerned the only reason
that the green and liberal Democrat and
independent group was to put up eight
and 26 Pence rise in council tax was
purely to support adult social care
which of course is not a service that
this Council has to deal with thank you
oh thank you counselor
so there are no more hands up and just
for clarity uh obviously we've got
people that have been on the council for
a short period of time uh normally go
for guillotine on this we have the
consent to carry on um because as
councilor burn rightly said this is an
important subject and it must be heard
so uh councilor Whitehead do you have
anything further to add
hello sorry yes
um now I'm very conscious of time and
obviously we've got the HRA budget and
another item still to go so I'm very
very brief really
um I do take on board I have heard the
comments across all the opposition
um as Castle Stringer said about council
tax increase should be kept to a minimum
it seems like I could have a new best
friend there and I'll try my best not to
disappoint him this time next year
because this time next year we should
have much clearer picture of the the
future government settlements
um the um but beyond that
um I think I said all I wanted to say in
terms of our first speech and my answers
to various questions so I commend this
budget to the council and I hope you'll
be passed thank you
thank you
um so I will now ask the corporate
manager governance of Civic office to
conduct the recorded votes I will take
item 3.1 and 3.2 together as amended and
it's been some time since we've heard it
so I'll read out 3.1 specifically which
was the uh the addition of the words 3.1
that the general fund budget proposals
for 2021-22 and four years Outlook set
out in the report be approved and that
recommendations to Cabinet be prepared
using a balanced cross-party approach
for the allocation of the additional
four million pounds of funding for
investment in our local community
economy housing and well-being of our
residents and in our communities this
cross-party approach would also give
consideration to the budget amendments
proposed in 2020 stroke 21 and 21 22 and
3.2 the general fund budget for 2021 22
is based on an increase to council tax
of 1 0.66 percent which equates to two
pounds 80 per annum or 23p per month for
a band D property
corporate management governance Civic
office please
clarify we are voting on 3.1 and 3.2 as
amended
um cancers could you please open the
vote in the modern.gov by clicking the
plus sign in the top right hand of the
agenda screen and select selecting the
vote the vote item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open it
thank you
um chairman this is Jessica I'm afraid
I'm unable to vote I think I must have
been shut out no problem uh we'll come
back to you councilor Fleming thank you
for letting us know
councilor Fleming can I take your vote
verbally then please
four thank you
thank you chair that is 17 4 16 against
and one abstention thank you
thank you that is carried I will now
take 3.3 and 3.4 together 3.3 is that
the flexible use of capital receipts
strategy and appendix be approved at 3.4
subject to approved by Council notified
the ministry of housing communities and
local governments of the adoption of the
strategy
thank you chair councilors if again if
you can open the vote in the modern.gava
app and click on the top right hand of
the screen it will show in blue please
please click on the blue line to open
the vote thank you
can I just point out that the record in
the um shows that the last vote was
drawn
oh I'm guessing that's because one was
done manually
yeah yeah that's absolutely right and
thank you for raising it anyway but
you're absolutely right in the reason
cancer Carter we're still waiting for
your vote
um if you cannot um are not able to vote
would you oh it's just come through
thank you
thank you chair the voting was 31 4 2
against and one abstention thank you
thank you that is carried now I'm
conscious that we've been here for about
three hours uh and we all need to have a
leg stretch because we need to be sharp
for the next uh agenda point and I think
councilor Whitehead needs a breather so
please
um we're going to take a 10 minute
refreshment break uh please be back here
in 10 minutes so let's say in fact just
over 10 minutes let's make it 20 to the
eye
thank you
uh welcome back everybody
um we're now going to move on to the
housing revenue account budget for your
outlook so I'd like to invite councilor
Whitehead to introduce paper mc20 25 and
move the recommendations of the report
again I'm minded to allow councilor
Whitehead and councilor field and their
second is longer than the time normally
allowed in his circumstances all other
counselors will of course have three
minutes councilor Whitehead
thank you chairman
yes it's getting late in the evening I'd
like to introduce now report
mc2025 this HRA budget in draft was
first reviewed and endorsed by cabinet
at the January cabinet meeting
it was subsequently scrutinized by
myself scrutiny committee at their
meeting on the 14th of July
and grateful for the work that ons does
as an important integral part of our
budgeting process and thank them for
their endorsement to this HRA budget
the budget returned to Cabinet in
February unchanged other than just some
very minor expense editions of 14 000
pounds
for the year 2122 are forecasting a
surplus on the HRA of 102 000. this
contrasts with a larger deficit of 564
000 in the 2021 budget however primarily
due to slippage in our Capital program
we are now forecasting a surplus for
2021.
the table in paragraph 5.2 compares the
budgets for the two years with
explanations behind the various line
movements set out in detail in paragraph
5.5
savings and efficiencies have been
identified during a robust budget
setting process
despite the distractions arising from
the pandemic the housing team has
introduced some significant improvements
during 2020 and these are set out under
the key headings key achievements on
page 103.
I'd like to talk a little bit about our
council tax rents in April 20 we
increased our Council of rents by 2.7
percent being the CPI plus an additional
one percent this was our first increase
after four years of a central government
imposed reduction of rents by one
percent each year
for the coming year starting first of
April 21. an increase based on September
20 CPI plus one percent works out to be
an increase of 1.5 percent or an average
increase of one pound 25 per week
however a six-year period the net effect
of these decreases then increases is
that our average Council house weekly
rent in March 22 will be 84.49 that's
only marginally Higher by just 11 Pence
than it was back in March 2016.
we will not be changing our sheltered
housing utility charges to 2122 there is
an element of subsidy presently built
into these charges we have seen
reductions in the price of gas
electricity and especially oil
we can therefore freeze these utility
prices 2122 while still making some
reduction in a level of subsidy
members will recall that we did not
increase sheltered housing service
charges in this current year
there remains an element of subsidy
these charges and to totally eliminate
this subsidy in 2021-22 we would need to
increase the service charges by two
pound 90. we are not proposing to make
such an increase the recommendation for
next year is an increase of just one
pound per week
it is my hope that we can find
cross-party support for such a modest
increase particularly as it follows on
from two years of zero increases
members should note as mentioned within
paragraph 5.5 that we have plans to
develop a rent and service charge policy
for our sheltered housing during 2021
with a view to bringing it into effect
from 22-23
turn into Capital members will see that
we have an ambitious Capital program for
the four years from 21 to 25 working
within seni the council has identified
development sites for 254 affordable
homes and 119 shared ownership homes
new bills and Acquisitions are forecast
to cost 42.2 million and our housing
maintenance program 15.8 million and
appendix a on page 109 shows how we
intend to finance this Capital program
finally I'll draw members attention to
one of the most important paragraphs in
the report that is paragraph 4.2
this explains how we will be reviewing
our 30-year HRA business plan to
incorporate new build specifications the
design code
environmental retrofit improvements and
new safety enhancements this new
business plan articulating our vision
for Council housing should be coming to
cabinet and Council by this summer
I'd now like to remove the
recommendation set out in paragraph
three would ask councilor hadtingham the
member I can't remember for housing to
kindly second them thank you
Council Halligan are you seconding the
uh yes I'm happy happy secondary this
report and I'd like to refer my right to
speak
yep that's absolutely fine thank you
I would now like to invite councilor
Phil to propose the Amendments from the
green and liberal Democrat group Council
field
thank you Jim
I'm sure it will be grateful if I keep
this short I will try to do that and
we'll leave comments on the core of your
budget to to Anna's
uh our Amendment to the HRA budget is
simple and mostly proposes Capital spend
we propose a building of some houses
homes for social rather than affordable
rent
we believe there is an opportunity to
provide homes for the least well paid in
society
and it will be affordable to the council
Council if social value is adequately
taken into account
it may be that such homes would not
provide Revenue contribution to Virtual
build but that would be a small price to
pay for the need addressed
to move on WE suggest a specific sum a
minor some 30k assigned to the
production of a report we believe would
ensure that we have a clear
understanding of the problem we face in
upgrading our housing stock to meet our
zero carbon targets
this would be a small price to pay for a
basis on which who can plan our path to
2030.
we propose a somewhat larger Capital sum
250k next year or this year and 500k in
the second year to allow us to explore
the techniques and the skills necessary
to upgrade our housing stock to remove
reduce emissions and heat loss
we believe that Exemplar conversions
would do much to reduce uncertainty in
the market give us another's valuable
data to play in the future and trusted
information we could Supply to
individuals and small businesses
we would of course Advocate exploration
of similar projects Elsewhere for
instance at building research
establishments to ensure we are not
duplicating existing knowledge
that's short and sweet and that is it we
would welcome your support
thank you councilor field could I have a
second there
Council War boys again
Coastal War boys
yep on my way
thank you thank you chair
uh I'm happy to Second this amendment to
the housing Revenue budget
our amendment is in addition to the
existing building and acquisition
program
we propose this amendment to achieve the
aspirational goals as described by the
Norse group in their design guide in our
social housing
in particular purchase zero carbon
targets and meet the passive house
standard are equivalent
this is to have examples of social
housing that are literally as good as
current technology can make them that
show what can be achieved and give us
the opportunity to assess their success
we predict that these will be more
expensive initially
we think that however in the long term
maintenance costs will be reduced that
debt will be reduced tenant health is
approved improved both physically and
mentally and local economic activity
will increase
these houses will be test beds for new
approaches another huge trading
possibilities
so that we have a reservoir of people
with the necessary skill sets to achieve
our goals
alongside this we need to know as
accurately as possible what needs to be
done in order to meet our 2030 goals so
we're proposing a detailed survey and
roadmap of requirements
and accelerate the upgrading of our
houses stock with the immediate aim of
producing example conversions to raise
public awareness of what is possible
this will be good for private
Property Owners as well as uh our own
this amendment recognizes that we have a
responsibility as a major provider of
housing to take the lead in providing
21st century housing that meets the
challenge of climate change and in doing
so also brings economic result
resilience
a game this proposely supportiveless
council's strategic priorities and has
been scrutinized by the section 151
officer and is achievable without
compromising the setting of a balanced
budget no result in any increase to
council tax or rents
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Whitehead
do you accept this amendment
thank you these opposition HRA budget
amendments are primarily capital
expenditure with only very modest
Revenue spend the capital proposed in
this amendment totals 5.25 million over
two years
as I said in my introduction we are
planning to spend 4.4 I was planning to
spend 42.2 million on new bills and
Acquisitions over four years and 15.8
million on our housing maintenance
program we've identified sites for 254
affordable homes 119 shared ownership of
homes
and we are bringing we will be bringing
an ambitious new 30-year HRA business
plan forward very shortly
I'm sure officers will have listened
closely to these opposition suggestions
as this new plan is developed
but there for us as an Administration we
cannot accept we can see no reason to
accept these far more modest opposition
proposals thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead in that
case we must move to debate to debate
the amendment uh before voting on it so
that's what we're going to do
so there are no questions obviously this
is an amendment but we are into debate
and I see councilor Austin that you are
hands up first
uh thank you very much I think there's a
huge amount to recommend this amendment
at the moment there is a severe lack of
people needing good well insulated
good social housing I believe the need
for well managed social housing is
something that is going to be essential
in the coming years many families will
find that they are unable to provide the
level of heating and
um
costs for themselves in the coming years
and I really believe that the council
could take on this amendment and
therefore provide incredibly
Innovative forms of social housing in
the coming years thank you
thank you councilor and councilor Eber
please
thank you very much chair
um this this amendment looks to go
faster and further than what is
currently within the HRA budget before
you today what we're doing is really
looking to the Future
we should have been doing with our
previous
um programs of build been looking to up
the environmental performance of these
ensuring they're for social rent and not
affordable rent and really equipping
them for um Beyond 21st century
um inhabitants and we want to go much
further than is is within the HRA
this amendment would take that further
it's been mentioned that um
there is a potential new plan coming
forward but we are not aware of that so
perhaps in the new spirit of of um
meetings with the um Administration
we will be they will be able to share
that with us but as we do not know what
that is at the moment we can't we can't
comment and as such we've put our
amendment in in
um
with Goodwill and to make sure that we
can actually improve on the lives of
those people that need secure social
tenancies within mid-suffolk thank you
chair
thank you counselor are there any other
counselors that wish to enter debate
uh councilor Mansell please
uh thank you chair
um yeah whilst I I think it's fantastic
that we we have a a building program to
build our own Council houses and make
further section 106 Acquisitions uh to
try to address the balance of the
properties that we are losing to write
to buy
now there's always a bit of a misnomer
with the words affordable housing and
what is really meant by affordable
um councilor Whitehead has just
mentioned that that the bill program
that we are uh that the administration
are promoting is for affordable homes
and shared ownership homes
um and what we really need to be doing
is is is committing to build some of our
own houses which will be at Social rent
not affordable rent
affordable rent is is about 80 percent
of the current market rate but there are
lots of people for whom that this is
still not truly affordable so we need to
ensure that a greater proportion of our
Council housing is for social rent not
affordable rent and not shared ownership
where we can reduce those rent levels to
make them much more affordable
uh you know mid-suffolk has a very high
house price uh when compared to the
average wage and and that for it
therefore housing is as expensive in
this part of the country
uh so that is why we are proposing that
that we need to have many more Homes at
Social rent
um we've also had um a discussion of the
um
retrofitting the low-carbon energy
sources uh energy sources for heating in
the homes
um our carbon zero Target of 2030 I
think is a challenging Target to make
and our budget proposal aims to speed up
that uh um program of of getting more of
our Council houses on low carbon energy
and also
um we'll we'll hopefully make the
um cost to the tenants in order to heat
those homes much more affordable
therefore they will be able to pay their
rent uh more easily and it will lessen
our debt so so to me it's a win-win
situation and we really as others have
already said before me we should be
um really trying to build Exemplar homes
to be a great example to other
developers we we should be committing to
the Social and Community benefits as
much as the financial benefits of
building new homes thank you
thank you councilor councilor geek
please
thank you chair
uh my view is that we need social
housing it's the only way that we can
solve the housing crisis affordables
just don't cut it for teaching
assistance for shop workers for anyone
on the average range and I'm afraid I
have to include my own profession
archaeologists among people who earn
really very little we need it not only
to provide good warm homes we also need
it so that we can enable people to save
up deposits to buy their own homes which
is what most of us genuinely want to do
in addition if we provide these
exemplars a best practice this lessens
the risk of innovation to others so it
encourages owner occupiers to follow
suit it encourages them it enables them
to take individual responsibility for
their properties and I think those
things being able to save up a deposit
and being able to take a risk of
improving your house those are important
to all of us thank you
thank you counselor do you have anybody
else that wishes to enter debate
councilor
omarosan please
hello thank you uh just very briefly
just to add
um I encourage all councilors to
um
vote for this amendment I think it's a
real opportunity to to Pioneer and show
leadership we're here and in the spirit
of of well-being and the thriving
communities
um as as was highlighted and waxed about
in the in the budget debate I think this
is a an opportunity to to to embrace
those those values for for us all thank
you
thank you and councilor mathiason please
thank you very briefly just to remind
members that the previous Council
um
voted for the council to go ahead and
provide some passive house designs we
did propose that we a pilot project of
building and the conservative group
reduced that from from building them to
do some designs but I haven't actually
seen the designs yet and and that must
be three years ago or something thank
you
thank you councilor anybody else
okay I'm going to come back then to uh
councilor field uh have you anything
additional that you'd like to uh to add
I think the answer to that is no uh
people have covered uh points more than
adequately thank you
thank you councilor and also the
councilor y said anything else that you
wish to add
well not really only as the far as the
30-year business plan that's expected
this summer will be quite ambitious and
I suppose it's two to being an ask to
expect the opposition to draw their
motion just off the back of that but if
but again I'm sure well I'm sure
officers will have been taking careful
note of what uh the opposition have said
in terms of their aspirations for social
housing and
um
that's all I have to say really
thank you in that case I'll now ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct record a vote on the
amendment
thank you chair councils could you
please open the vote in the app by
clicking the plus sign in top right hand
of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance and voting voting tab for
this agenda item will show in blue
please click on the blue line to open
the vote thank you
sure I haven't got a blue line
um chair if I could cancel Brewster if
you can scroll down you you will see the
blue line
are you able to find it if not we'll
take your vote manually
it should be there thank you
thank you chair the voting was 16 for
the amendment and 18 against thank you
thank you that is lost uh we'll now go
back to the original motion where we'll
enter questions followed by debates
um so we're going to the questions and
just a reminder you can ask as many
questions as you like but it must be
relevant and it must be a question
who wants to start
are there no questions I'll give you a
couple more seconds
okay councilor field just in
so only the reactions aren't as good as
they could be
not surprised but expecting
the response I I was just a question to
to council Whitehead really um he he
covered the point about the um the
government the assistance on a one
percent reduction in uh Council rents in
affordable rent I guess over a period of
four years I wondered if he could
explain on why he thinks that was that
was done what was what was the purpose
of that reduction
councilor Whitehead please
gosh I can't transmember back I mean
this was something that wasn't was
announced in 2015
um I off the top of my head I can't
recall just the whole basis of that I
mean obviously it did uh for four years
decreased rents by over four percent or
one percent times four compounded and it
certainly didn't help our HRA account
and
um it's but um sorry I don't know if
Gavin or one of the officers can can
recall better than I can what uh at the
base is four years ago I could always
help you if you wish oh it's a
rhetorical question
so that we don't enter into any form of
debate so you've asked the question
let's bring in the uh chief executive
who might have the answer
I'll give you what I believe to be the
answer which is it was it was simply
government policy um so our rents are to
some degree still controlled by
government and government therefore
obliged us to reduce our rents year on
year at that time I'm sure that also had
a net benefit in terms of their overall
uh housing benefit bill as well uh for
for government in terms of those costs
uh yes government policy were obliged to
do so that government policy has changed
and so we're no longer obliged to do so
thank you
uh moving on then to councilor Ebert
please
thank you very much chair
um I've just got a couple of questions
if I may at 5.12
um it refers to the capital program and
refers to homes that are for affordable
rent and for shared ownership
um my first question is is there a
possibility of
amending that Capital program so that we
aren't we are actually
um having some homes within that Capital
program that are for social rent
um because I think that is what our
communities need and especially at the
moment so they can reduce their their
rent
um and secondly
um I understand that the council is
making purchases Off plan as it were of
various housing developments that are
going on
um could someone confirm I think the
answer is is yes but can they confirm
that those are that none of those for
social rent and again my question would
be is there a possibility to renegotiate
or negotiate better so that some of
those homes are for social rent thank
you chair
thank you
um rather than attempt to answer those
questions myself I would like to ask
Gavin fiskers the ad for housing to give
his views for me
yes please thank you councilor Whitehead
and thank you chair I think um in all
honesty in answer to the question
um the program of activity in relation
to those homes outlined in the budget
report
um there is unlikely to be any
opportunity to to change
um the approach being taken um obviously
as part of funding for new homes we
attract homes England funding uh and uh
that funding will have been set um in
advance hence uh section 106 properties
that we are currently purchasing will
also be for affordable rent because that
is part of the policy that Holmes
England introduced in in order to to
receive the funding Holmes England have
announced uh very recently a new program
of activity over the fourth coming years
and it's yet to be seen obviously uh
what impetus they put on social rent
within that program of activity
um I don't know whether
um Emily
uh ATAC would like to add anything as
the assistant director for assets and
Investments
thank you Emily
good evening
um just to confirm that we do have some
social rent properties within our
program and so I'm aware of
um
the schemes that we are bringing forward
ourselves directly so things like um the
need Market Middle School site
um and Stone Market Middle School site
will have um social rent properties as
well as affordable rent properties
um in terms of the section 106
properties that we acquire and we
acquire those based on
um the tenure that has been agreed
through the planning process so the
planning process sets and the proportion
of social affordable and shared
ownership rents within those schemes so
we acquire those based on on those
principles that have been established as
part of that process and so I hope that
helps
yeah can I come back
um the
um
the program that's noted at 5.12
um totals um
you know 300 73
um homes
um so
in terms of the ones that are being
brought forward what would you say as a
percentage of the um program for the
next three years then that fell into
social rent
I haven't looked at those figures but
I'm more than happy to have a look at
that outside the meeting and come back
to you councilor e burn if that's okay
thank you very much I would appreciate
that but could you send that to all
members as well thank you certainly
thank you are there any other questions
before we move to debate
okay we're now moving to debate again
you can speak once uh you have three
minutes and you will be timed in you're
all very good last time so let's stick
to that three minutes who wants to start
the debate
okay councilor Phil please
again I'll keep this brief uh I I think
there have been some comments in within
the questions which would indicate that
it would be really advantageous if the
opposition groups were kept informed
about the direction of travel
it's quite clear that
uh we were just told that there are some
hounds for social rent being Acquired
and that's something clearly we would
upload that's a good thing to be doing
we film
since there are a range of income levels
certain people have and that they all
need homes whatever your income so I I
think I would really encourage that on
the point of my question particularly on
uh on the reason for the government's
policy to reduce rents by one percent
per annum my perception was that at that
time we were encouraging we were
increasing rents at CPI plus one percent
and we've been doing that for some years
and as counselors we opposition
councilors we were told uh don't worry
your head about the affordability of
these rents counselors those people on
the lowest incomes will be on housing
benefit so it really isn't something to
worry about
of course it proved to worry the
government considerably since their
housing benefit bill went up quite
substantially
and I feel we could head exactly the
same way at the moment you know we are
again not just Rising with inflation
which seems to be fully to me to be
fully justifiable but a rate above
inflation
particularly in a particularly Grim year
for everyone's income
so I think that for those reasons
I basically will be um not supporting
this budget
with some regrets there are clearly some
good elements within it and clearly I
have put all the building of more houses
we'll be very pleased to see the details
of what that entails when we get hang
the new plan but there has been no
cross-party involvement in that plan
thank you
thank you councilor moving on to
councilor e-bone please
thank you very much chair um and thank
you to John Whitehead for putting this
paper forward
um councilor Whitehead um refers to
hoping that he'll get cross-party
support for the recommendations within
this paper
now that's a request that he has made at
five minutes past nine on the day of a
budget meeting in the evening
perhaps
um if he had um contacted us or you know
I'm on the phone email back in October
when this draft budget was being put
together that would have been far more
preferable in terms of if if the um
there is a spirit of working together
then why was that you know why is it
being initiated at 9 00 pm on a Thursday
evening why can that you know the
administration hold the um
you know the the decision making so why
can they not put forward
um an open invitation back in October
before these draft budgets are even put
together and say this is what we're
considering you know what do you think
have you got any ideas they can turn our
ideas down of course but that would
really be a way of actually getting us
to um get get more support and I'm sure
many of us would be very willing to do
that
um with regards to the housing in
particular
um we really must refocus this Council
on social rent it is not acceptable to
have hundreds of people just on
affordable rent it is too high a
percentage of of private rent in terms
of um especially with the current covid
pandemic and with people looking to
ending ending Furler Arrangements people
losing their jobs there's a very high
proportion of um of women losing jobs
compared to men at the moment and we
need to be able to support these people
with housing that has social rent not
affordable rent and I would really
strongly ask that this Council refocuses
its efforts on that
similarly we need to have a much much
much larger retrofit program not just
the odd 50 houses that are happening
through a green homes Grant but a huge
program across the whole of our three
and a half thousand of council owned
properties we really need to get bills
down for people living in those homes we
need to ensure that their homes are
safely insulated so that it improves
their health with people with asthma and
those sorts of issues we must must do
this and the program that's put forward
to date just isn't ambitious enough
again we could use other forms of
funding in this regard and I know there
are ways of doing this which I'm sure
officers can um
can look into
and finally it with upgrads to our own
new build you know can we all hand on
heart say that the new build that we
this council is doing are truly highly
environmentally sustainable and with
strong social values so that the people
that live in them have got low bills and
again they go back to the health issues
and socially if someone has less to pay
on their heating bills and so on they
are more likely to go out and get work
for
um part-time and full-time job than not
so in conclusion chair I would say that
we want to refocus on social rent look
for a much larger retrofit program and
our new build must be exemplary to show
other developers what what they should
be capable of thank you very much thank
you for your time thank you and uh
councilor scarf please
yeah thank you chair um well I wanted to
sort of focus on a slightly different
area of the report and that was the
right to buy sales
um on page 105 and I refer to the I mean
it came to scrutiny and I was part of
that process
um we're told that we sold just 12
against an original projection of 20
sales
um and the money that we received from
those sales uh can only be used as a 30
contribution towards the cost of a
replacement home I've always wondered
why that is
um you would think that right to buy
would allow us to build new and modern
and effective uh Properties by selling
older properties that may be needed to
be improved by the uh making extra value
by the purchaser
um the remaining 70 has got to be found
from other resources and of course this
really so many important is if if the
receipts that we get from that 30 are
not spent within the three year period
um they've got to be paid back to
government central government we four
percent above the base rate interest
added now
um and a 5.19 we're told as to why
obviously with covid-19 we've had some
serious delays in the council's housing
development program doing uh 2020 2021
um and of course
the ability then of the council to spend
the full amount which could have an
impact on us actually ending up paying
money back to the government which I
find quite perverse and the officers
have focused on an alternative program
to achieve the spending by purchasing
existing houses and suitable Land from
the open market before March 2021 which
obviously is fast approaching and it
says in conclusion that the actions will
minimize any repayments that may be due
back to the government I I would hope
that we would go stronger than that and
say that we would eradicate any
repayments back because I find the whole
situation perverse when we sell a house
that actually we only get to keep 30 of
that house so I would encourage officers
to work really hard to actually make
sure that we don't actually pay any
money back and we don't pay any interest
on that money either
that would be my point yeah thank you
thank you very much councilor uh
councilor Mansell please
uh thank you chair I I won't um repeat
what my fellow councilors have already
been saying because I I agree
wholeheartedly with all three speakers
who've just spoken but I would like to
um mention I would like to discuss the
um sheltered housing service charge
which is a recommendation 3.4
um and and I I do welcome the fact that
we are going to be making a a rent and
sheltered housing policy payment policy
um because
um you know at the moment I think I
think it's it it's probably not quite a
fair system in terms of the service
charges uh for sheltered housing uh but
but I just want to focus really on on
the amount that we're actually
increasing it
um we've been discussing whether we
should have a CPI percent uh CPI
increase on the council house rents or
whether we go for CPI plus one
um and we're talking about a rent
increase of 1.25 a week that's on on the
rent
um of the house now I'm quite sure that
the service charges are not as high as
the rents but please correct me if I'm
wrong uh and we always talk about
service charge increases in terms of the
actual amount rather than a percentage I
would actually quite like to know what
the percentage increase
um on the sheltered housing service
charge is going to be because those
people who are living in sheltered
housing are probably the of the most
vulnerable in our communities
um so so this this um uh paper is
suggesting that they're paying uh 1.25 a
week more on their rent and one pound a
week more on their service charge
and that it may be an awful lot of money
for for these people who are in the
sheltered housing so I I really don't
think I I could support it I know last
year it wasn't put up and it wasn't put
up the year before which is why we
really do need to have a look at this
policy so whilst I welcome the policy I
don't welcome the increase in the in the
service charges thank you
thank you councilor I'm moving on to
councilor Mathison please
thank you chair very brief we spend
quite a lot of time and money
um measuring carefully housing need and
the the answer to housing need question
is answer we need more social housing
and that is that is a very simple
reality and so I just implore
offices and administration to to wrestle
the finances with with Holmes England
and and our money and
deliver the maximum possible propulsion
of social rent
thank you
thank you councilor councilor Stringer
please
uh thank you thank you chair uh I don't
want to repeat anything that anyone else
has said I just want to make the point
why we need to have quite a radical
program of retrofitting and making our
properties fit for a low-carbon society
someone gave me a newspaper the other
day from April the 10th 1963 and I've
got it in front of me here one of the
interesting articles in it is a wedding
of a certain Gerard Brewster but it also
has an article about how the council was
offering to sell homes
hartersmere rural District Council is to
offer for sale to the tenants 18 houses
standing in pairs in isolated sites in
bacton and cotton among other Villages a
price of 650 pounds will be asked for
each house this is the outcoming of the
vote 14 votes to five at Monday
evening's meeting in eye Mr Gordon smye
resident of cotton as it happens
chairman of the housing committee said
that in Rand figures the cost of
providing drainage alone would cost 700
pounds there's a lesson there from
history we had to sell homes that we
hadn't modernized and moved with the
times and I think we need to have that
radical program so not only are is it
are our housing actually affordable to
live in and heat
Etc but equally we don't don't want to
relearn the lessons of History thank you
chair
thank you councilor are there any other
people that wish to enter debate
okay councilor hadingham uh you reserved
your right to speak do you wish to speak
now
um yes please
thank you
thank you I would like to thank my
fellow cabinet minister for finance for
his introduction to the HRA budget for
this year
2021-22 as the cabinet member for
housing I'm fortunate to see firsthand
the work of the housing service every
day the income of HRA receives is
invaluable in supporting our tenants by
ensuring their homes are safe and decent
places tenants are proud to call home
the work of our team supports tenants to
manage and maintain their tenancies
while supporting them to succeed and
thrive
this year as with many Council Services
the impact of the covert pandemic has
impacted on the housing service however
officers have continued to provide
exceptional Services adjusting to
working in new ways and finding
opportunities to maintain Service
delivery and develop new ways of working
which have made Services even more
efficient as set out in this report this
report demonstrates our investment in
new homes and in Capital Improvements to
our existing homes over the short term
whilst our HRA business plan to be
presented later this year will provide
insight to our medium and long-term
investments in our houses including the
safety quality and Energy Efficiency of
them
as portfolio holder for housing I would
like to take the opportunity to Second
this report and the recommended
recommendations set out within it in
paragraph three thank you very much
thank you and councilor Whitehead have
you anything else to add
uh thank you chair oh just a couple of
quick points on the sheltered housing uh
you know babe we've got 13 sites of 262
units and they and over they have 12
different charging rates over those 12
sites whereas in Miss Suffolk we've got
14 sites 285 units and we have one
common charge at the moment 30 pound 85
a week so the one pound increase is 3.24
I think I hope that answers some of the
questions that councilor Mansell raised
whilst once the debate was on I was just
pulling up on my computer the speech I
made the cabinet on the 4th of 8th the
4th of January and I said in there I
would hope that we can find cross-party
support for such modest increases that's
in the sheltered housing so that wasn't
at 10 8 10 p.m today it was it on the
4th of January and then similarly
um on the the ons uh telling us on the
14th of January I said the same thing I
actually said I would sincerely hope
that we can find cross-party supports
which might just increase so it's not
really been sprung on at the last moment
um but um so I just wanted to make those
two points but beyond that I just again
I just commend the budget and hope it is
adopted thank you
thank you councilor um before we go to
the vote
um there might be an expectation that we
take these uh either in small groups or
or single items but it's on the advice
from the section 151 officer because
these recommendations are all
interdependent of each other and we're
going to take the vote on block so
before I go to the corporate manager
governance Civic office to conduct
recorded vote I will go through the
recommendations as a reminder to
everybody what you're voting upon so 3.1
at HRA budget proposals for 2021-22 and
for your outlook set out and Report be
approved
3.2 that's CPI plus one percent increase
of 1.5 percent in Council house rents
equivalent to an average rent increase
of one pound 25 a week be implemented
3.3 that Gary's rents are kept at the
same level as 20 20 21 uh 3.4 that
sheltered housing service charges be
increased by one pound per week to
ensure recovery of the actual cost of
service
that sheltered housing uh sorry 3.5
sheltered housing utility charges are
kept at the same level as 2020 2021
and 3.6 that the budgeted surplus of 102
000 pounds be transferred to Street
strategic priorities Reserve in 2021-22
and 3.7 that in principle right to buy
receipts should be retained
to enable continued development and
acquisition of new Council dwellings
I'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the recorded vote
thank you chair councilors again if you
can open the vote in the modern.gov app
you may need to scroll down to get the
blue line this time so if you can look
down further you will find the vote
opening then thank you
cancer Pratt we're still awaiting your
vote please can you vote or if you
cannot vote please can you let me have
your vote manually thank you oh okay
it's just come through thank you
thank you chair we have 17 4 16 against
and one abstention thank you
thank you that is carried
moving on now to recommendations reports
from cabinet committees we'll look at
mc20 stroke 26 joint capital investment
treasury management strategies for 2021
2022 I'd like to invite councilor Buller
to introduce the paper and move the
recommendations in this report thank you
very much chair
um this report is the capital investment
and treasury management strategies for
2020-21
there have been no significant changes
in format this year and it has been
updated to reflect the latest capital
expenditure investment and borrowing and
the latest treasury management
investment and borrowing positions of
the council
under the sit for treasury management
code of practice and the Prudential code
both published in 2017 and the ministry
of housing communities and local
government investment guidance published
in 2018 we are required to determine
separate capital investment and treasury
management strategy statements and
Prudential indicators annually before
the start of each Financial year
I will now run through the appendices
appendix a the capital strategy this
summarizes the capital expenditure and
financing requirements of the full
Capital program for for both the general
fund and the housing revenue account the
details of which are in the budget
report this out capital expenditure and
capital investment decisions and the
associated risks and rewards along with
how risk is managed for future Financial
sustainability
it includes potential indicators which
demonstrate that the investment plans of
the council are affordable prudent and
sustainable and decisions are made
according to good practice
it shows that capital expenditure
applying for 2021 including carry
forward is 63.2 million of which 39.9
million will be funded by borrowing
limits and boundaries for borrowing are
set as part of the credential indicators
this the strategy shows that projected
borrowing will not exceed these limits
appendix B is the investment strategy
this details those expenditure items in
the capital program that specifically
relate to assets bought and or owned by
the council purely or partially to
generate a return this includes schemes
which have the purpose of regeneration
or development of the local area as well
as generating a return in the context of
this strategy investments means these
those non-treasury management activities
the ministry of housing communities and
local government defines these as two
types of Investments service provision
where the council lends to or buy shares
in organizations that provide a service
the caterer does not have any investment
under this category and Investments for
you which generate a return such as the
council owned companies sifco and
Gateway 14. the strategy explains how
each investment contributes to the
counter's priorities and its security
liquidity and risk it shows the
projected total investment of the
councils in sifco and Gateway 14 and
planned expenditure on the council's
property sale at least in part for
investment purposes a key change for
2122 is the Public Works loan board
borrowing is no longer available for
authorities that have plans to purchase
property purely for yield the strategy
therefore shows all sithco Investments
being completed in 2021 so that the
council can continue to access the pwlb
borrowing facility appendix C A treasury
management strategy 2021 sets out the
council's borrowing requirement and
borrowing and treasury management
investment strategies this also includes
a list of approved investment
counterparties and limits there has been
no significant change since since the
limit since last year the 2020 sorry for
2122 information on the performance of
the council's pulled funds and
environmental social and government
issues has been included appendix D is
the treasury management indicators which
we use to measure and manage the
council's exposure to treasury
management risks appendix e the economic
update and interest rate forecast the
combined effect of brexit and the after
effects of the pandemic will dampen
growth relative to peers maintain spare
capacity and limit domestically
generated inflation the bank of England
are therefore expected to maintain loose
monetary conditions for the foreseeable
future
the council's treasury management
advisor I'll enclosed is forecasting
that the bank of England bank rate will
remain at 0.1 percent until at least the
first quarter of 2024 the risks of this
forecast are just to be to the downside
as the bank of England and the UK
government continue to react to the
coronavirus pandemic and the new
European Union trading Arrangements
appendix F current investment and debt
portfolio shows the position at 30th of
November 20. mid suffolk's borrowing
totals 123 million of which 99 million
is long-term and 24 million short term
on the investment side Miss Suffolk is
15 million invested this includes ccla
UBS Schroeder's investec and funding
Circle we have continued the policy of
withdrawing funds from funding Circle as
loans drop out and we have not invested
any new money appendix G treasury
management policy statement underpins
the strategy and sets out both counts
with regard to the monitoring of risk
and performance and the primary
objectives remain security of capital
then liquidity followed by return there
has been no change from the last year
appendix H minimum Revenue provision
statement which shows the basis of how
we put aside the resources to repay debt
in later years this has not changed from
last year's statement appendix I is
institutions meeting High credit ratings
criteria and appendix J is the glossary
of terms I'd like to move the
recommendation 3.1 to 3.7 as detailed in
uh pages one one three two one one four
of our papers for a second to please
thank you
thank you could I have a second
councilor casting
thank you very much Mr chairman I'd like
to second that as Patel by councilor
Muller
thank you thank you councilors uh we're
now going to move to questions and as a
reminder you can ask as many questions
as you like however they must be
relevant and to the subject matter under
discussion that must be a question
councilor e-burn
thank you very much chair um thank you
um councilman for that introducing that
report
um with regards to
um
the
in the appendices we refer to the ESG
reports which is the Environmental
social and governance reports um and
then Council of War boys mentioned them
earlier this evening in relation to
Gateway 14. now reading that that report
which is Page 152
um there seems to be a reticence of the
council to actually
um Implement ESG reports and it says
it'll be looked at um in due course and
I paraphrase
um could you explain to me why there's
such a reticence and secondly
um what time frame we will actually be
um utilizing ESG reports on our
investments thank you very much thank
you for your question councilor even I
could I'd like to ask the assistant
director and finance Catherine still
which you could possibly answer those
questions please thank you chair yes
please
thank you
thank you chair
um I wouldn't say that there is
reticence I think we need to have the
the right conditions to be able to do it
and we need to be able to take some
money out of some existing funds to be
able to move them into into other funds
at the moment we aren't in a position to
be able to do that there was a long
discussion at the during order and
standards committee about ESG and the
committee has asked for a further report
on this to go back to their meeting in
uh the May the May meeting so we will be
preparing further information and
considering the issues further at that
meeting
um thank you very much for that and if I
can come back so if it's been considered
in May when would be the earliest that
that would be
um if it was agreed to take that forward
when would be the earliest that
um we would
um start implementing that thank you
I'm afraid I can't give you a time scale
until we've actually pulled pulled the
report together and had the discussion
obviously joint audit and standards has
asked for that to come forward
um but my understanding is that it would
actually be a cabinet decision because
it would be a policy decision as to what
the SG policy we we adopt so I'm
anticipating that during audit and
standards will probably make a
recommendation to to cabinet
thank you now presumably other councils
do this as well but I'll follow that up
in in due course thank you very much
thank you thank you Catherine thank you
councilors are there any other questions
excellent okay we're going to move to
debate now
um each counselor can speak once
for a period of three minutes only and
you will be timed councilor Mathias
please
yes following the question from
councilor e Byrne the problem is quite
simple our treasury management policy is
not supporting our climate change policy
and um you know we've been trying to
move forward on this for a long time
that the county-wide pensions committee
has moved forward it's saved a great
deal of the staff and Pension funds
money that they did so in a timely way
and I just wish we'd get on with it as
well thank you
thank you counselor any other people
wish to enter the debate
looks like nobody else has the hand up
so we are going to move to the vote
before we do though I will read out the
um the things we're going to vote on so
there's no confusion so 3.1 The Joint
Capital strategy for 2021-22 including
Prudential indicators as set out
appendix a 3.2 joint investment strategy
for 2122 has set out appendix B 3.3 The
Joint treasury management strategy for
21 22 including joints and your
investment strategy has set out in
appendix C
uh 3.4 The Joint treasury management
indicators set out appendix D 3.5 joint
treasury management policy statement set
out in appendix G 3.6 The Joint minimum
Revenue provision statement set out in
appendix H and 3.7 that the key factors
in information relating to an affecting
treasury management activities set out
independencies e f and I be noted
councilor Miller before I go to the vote
have you got anything else to add
uh thank you chair nothing else to add
thank you
thank you I'll now ask the corporate
manager governance of Civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councilors the vote is
now open again you may need to scroll
down to find the blue line thank you
foreign
can I ask you if you're going to cost a
casting vote
yes I will
and I'll Stow my original vote which is
four thank you
chair that is then 18 17. thank you that
is carried
it's moving on now to council
appointments is there any change to
policings
councilor Molly
thank you chair no
nothing nothing from me thank you thank
you
motions uh motion on notice
are there any
okay non-received okay uh before we
close the meeting I'd just like to thank
you all for your diligence tonight and
uh some really good debates uh very good
question but uh big thanks to the
councilors who put the work into those
reports uh special counselor field
councilor Whitehead and councilman
Muller thank you for your efforts
I'll be said it a few times tonight but
basically this skill commitment diligent
to our hard-working Finance team has to
be recorded and noted without them would
be pretty stuck so thank you for all
your hard work it is appreciated and
please keep it up
um a few key words or statements came
out tonight and there were stuff like
you know outputs and also things about
under promise over not overspend over
deliver and then value for money and
evidence-based spending but I think the
most important thing that came out
tonight was that cooperation that
cross-party work that we need to do and
I think uh that was evident tonight and
we'll be evident in the future I'm sure
so thank you for your attendance uh
thank you for your commitments and uh I
will close the meeting with the date of
the next meeting on Thursday the 25th of
March 2021 at
1730 good night